there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday it's the major show yeah the
major show
all our shows are major
the main show it's about Ted Kaczynski
it is a Unabomber I still can't believe
I had to keep checking I checked like
three times I'm like really we've never
done a show about Ted Kaczynski no
what's up oh she started all right okay
you started already she's like no not
the fan now they're talking to the left
oh that's right look at the fan okay
she's gotten really upset about that fan
lately I don't know what it is no I
don't have time but every time we turn
it on she starts like yelling at it
but yeah I was like yeah we haven't done
um we haven't done this show which is
crazy because I thought that we had done
it already
and uh I thought we'd also and I don't
think we did Timothy McVeigh either no
so we'll probably have to do that one of
these days as well but because I
remember when that happened well I
remember when this happened too mad
bombers yeah
I mean yeah I mean but this guy needs
his whole uh whole show like that we
can't just do a mad bomber show unless
it's like you're too too complicated
what and the cases are very different
and the the guys involved Ted Kaczynski
and Timothy McVeigh are two very
different dudes yeah yeah different
motives too um
Grandpa's Hammer said
what does the Unabomber Steve R and
grampler have in common
do you know they have a dicks
well yeah that's true but yeah I don't
know that's a little general yeah
I don't know what do they have in common
is this it's a little is it like a joke
or is it something like actual
because I didn't know I was like
expecting like a dad joke punchline or
something yeah but maybe not maybe not
the
yeah you're uh [ __ ] uh Unabomber did
a lot did quite a bit of damage
was crazy but not dumb you can find out
I've read his I've read his Manifesto
a lot of [ __ ] he was complaining about
the manifesto that actually did end up
happening
it's just um the way he went around his
the way he protested what was happening
was uh not the way to do it
um well he was one of those people that
was almost kind of like so intelligent
that it almost like in some aspects goes
around becomes dumb again yeah you know
what I mean kinda
it was pre-internet age that's true
that's had a lot to do with it so the
only way to get his message out was to
call attention to himself there was no
YouTube Back Then
I'll we'll get into it later but uh
he was trying to call attention to a
problem he saw Bruin
um although I think the ultimate
manifestation of what he saw was
he never would have lived to see it uh
he's still alive though yeah but
it's still 20 30 years away a lot of the
stuff it may be 50 years away some of
the stuff he was worried about
like
100 Gene edited people made by
corporations you could buy he's talking
about replicants like out of Blade
Runner he he figured that was coming
there was just a bunch of [ __ ] in his
Manifesto that he was worried about
and uh yeah you could probably you could
make a gene edited person probably but
bring them to Market and the the laws
involved and everything that's hundreds
of years away
he couldn't get it done yeah I'm not I'm
not really all that worried about it I
mean you know yeah I'm not all that
worried about it yeah Samantha said you
and Robert has a Manifesto that's how
you know you're maybe like treading on
some thin ice when you have a Manifesto
if you have a Manifesto just
went back now it is you just it's never
a good sign nowadays you just have a
YouTube channel
we don't have a Manifesto on our YouTube
channel we're just [ __ ] around yeah
um well a lot okay all right you trying
to get me to [ __ ] talk about it early
no I'm not I'm just saying well I just
commented on the thing but I was just
making a joke about oh grandpa said uh
the Unabomber and Steve attended the
University of Michigan and Grandpa works
there okay I probably I thought it
probably had something to do with uh
with the campuses John Smith's made a
very funny comment he said I'm guessing
their motives all boil out down to the
same thing a serious case of being a
[ __ ]
kind of probably true yes probably true
kind of I mean obviously
he wasn't dumb he was very intelligent
well yeah yeah and he foresaw a lot of
things that have already come to pass
and he didn't like it had to do with
what corporations were doing and
technocracy
um
well we'll get into it a minute we'll
talk about it later I don't want to get
ahead of myself
Danny rolling then said the Unabomber
needed to get laid and then maybe he
wouldn't have bombed some random [ __ ]
they weren't random I think he targeted
everybody
um well not exactly I think some people
opened things that they weren't supposed
to open but I I think he was he was
targeting heads of certain corporations
sometimes but then sometimes uh he was
picking people that were kind of like
adjacent to some [ __ ] he was mad about
but it was just a random person that
didn't have anything to do with and
sometimes too like he would pick
somebody that had uh something with like
wood in their name or something like
that they were some something uh he must
have thought they were linked to
something yeah linked to a [ __ ] I
mean he basically like I said it's like
he did Target you know the heads of
companies and stuff but then some of the
other people he targeted didn't really
seem to have anything to do with
anything like he just picked him out of
a book in a library or something I
thought they had something to do with
something though maybe I don't really
know
um thank you very much David June gave
us a Super Chat thank you very much uh
David Parker is here hey you two it was
great seeing you Saturday your costumes
were great thank you very much yeah we
had a good we didn't recognize that we
walk up to us
so who's this dude well it's funny
because when I went to when we went to
mannequins and I had my Medusa costume
on uh Tina came up and she like looked
right at me and then like went over and
talked and then like when I posted a
picture later she was like oh my God I
didn't know that was you
so it's like I was apparently
unrecognizable because a few people came
up and was like is that Jenny I didn't
think I looked that different but okay
David forgets how small I am in person
hahaha
you're so small yeah you're so small
that's what I say to Pokey all the time
why are you so
yeah she's tiny
DJ Maniac said Tom I'm gonna send John
Waters over to show you how to pencil
your bearded property
[Laughter]
it's so fun it's so funny
I told you told you what Big John said
[ __ ] these are so bikers [ __ ]
hangs out [ __ ] Oasis see a big old
big old morning long [ __ ] beers like
that come over here come on what's this
what's
this look like somebody for the kitty
milk doesn't work yeah you take a little
sauce of milk a little kitty come
lavender that's for Kitty milk let me
get some kitty milk
milk that's what they call it milk milk
yeah
John Smith said if you're writing a
Manifesto and you're not a political
figure maybe pause and rethink your life
actually even if you are a political
figure no but it's just dope don't write
a Manifesto okay uh Danny rolling said
wasn't Ted's mom sort of like Ed Gaines
mom I I don't really know
um there wasn't like a huge amount about
his mom I think his mom like didn't
she didn't really want to know it was
him because
um
I don't really want to like jump too far
ahead but uh one of his relatives did
turn him in
um it wasn't his mom but you know what I
mean but that's the thing like you never
want
you never want one of your relatives to
be like a mad bomber or a serial killer
or something like that you know what I
mean so it's like I get that they were
kind of just like oh [ __ ] like should we
tournament and [ __ ] like that
DJ Maniac said mine gets in the bowl
when I eat fruit LOL
yeah Daniel rolling spoiled that his
brother did his brother
um but yeah like so well actually it was
kind of like his sister-in-law like
convinced the brother of the tournament
which was absolutely the right thing to
do and I know that he felt bad about it
and [ __ ] but we'll get into that but I
mean he was killing people so
you know like I said whether he had some
decent ideas or whatever because yeah
like like I said some of the [ __ ] that
he wrote like sounds kind of crazy but
like some of the [ __ ] that he wrote like
sounded kind of legit and it's like some
of it was like you know like he had a
point and stuff but that doesn't justify
it was Harvard educated
yeah well he went to Harvard he went to
University of Michigan and he said yeah
we'll get into all that he's not dumb no
he was actually a like a super genius
right he and he was crazy per se
not in that way I think he was I think
he was suffering from a little bit of
delusion
yeah I think his imagination was running
with him running away with him I think
well he kind of I think he fell in some
stuff was real he was worried about some
of it wasn't that real I think he fell
into kind of one of those things that a
lot of very very highly intelligent
people fall into this too
um and we'll kind of get into like his
background and maybe you know it's you
know why things turned out the way they
turned out but I have uh known like some
very very intelligent people that
they're very very good at like in his
case mathematics but
um socially they're very socially
awkward they're very isolated
um and they have a hard time relating to
people so they're usually kind of like
loners and so they spend a lot of time
with themselves and with their own ideas
and inside their own heads and they
don't really have any outside uh
feedback I guess you know what I mean
and so it can kind of become a
self-perpetuating uh kind of and I think
that really like it it was an extreme
extreme in this case because he
deliberately like went off the grid like
away with from people and like didn't
see anybody for like long searches of
time you know yeah so I think that's
probably not
somebody like that I think he probably
would have been better if he'd like
stayed in but I mean you know I'm an
introvert too I get like not wanting to
hang out with other people and [ __ ] like
that but it's like
being inside your head like that all the
time and never seeing anybody ever like
talking to other people ever like that's
probably not a good thing especially
somebody with his level of intelligence
that's always going to end badly I'm
gonna say this right before we even get
into the case
had he been living during the age of the
internet the internet that you have
today none of this would have happened
because he wouldn't yeah probably not no
because he would have used different
techniques and he wouldn't have been
alone he'd have been in a in a group of
[ __ ] you YouTubers and [ __ ] and and
people on Twitter talking about this
yeah you know that that's which maybe
might have been better because yeah
because maybe he would have blown off
some steam and he wouldn't have felt the
need to like blow people up actually
blowing people off in the violence route
is actually counterproductive to to your
mission if you're trying to stop things
like technocracy
the best way to stop it is to expose it
so you need kind of like your own media
channel and your own reporters to try to
[ __ ] blow the lid off of things and
that actually is how you do it okay
if you
do things like blow [ __ ] up
what it does is it kind of sullies your
[ __ ] belief system and then they say
well that's just a violent conspiracy
theory for unabomers and even if it was
true they'll they'll use their that's
what I'm saying you're really shooting
yourself in the dick you're shooting
yourself in the dick basically what I
was you want to do kind of like what
[ __ ] AJ does if you're worried about
technology just keep talking about it
talking about talk and be it and that's
a far more effective
then [ __ ] acts of violence acts of
violence like this in this case don't
you guys know me [ __ ] Soldier
infantry 101st Airborne Division there
are there are there are a time for guns
sometimes that's what it takes but when
you're dealing with a [ __ ] problem
like he's talking about and ideas like
he's talking about that's the last thing
you want you just want to expose it and
talk about it and let everybody know
that things like this exist
I mean whatever that cause is I'm not
saying that I agree with it or disagree
with it I'm just saying that that's the
way of going about it the second you go
around like blowing up innocent ass
people which he did yeah um you can now
turn against everyone's just gonna go oh
well obviously you're a loon which kind
of you are because why would you that's
why you go that far you know yeah it's
like not only is that morally repugnant
it's also ineffective it's ineffective
so yeah there's certainly for what your
goal is there's certain tactics where
moral repugnance and outrage is what you
want but not in a case like this you
know
that yeah uh [ __ ] if you want [ __ ]
moral outrage you're in a situation like
the Mexican cartels where you weaponize
that you're not trying to be a good guy
you're trying to be maximum bad guy
that's what yeah but like their goals
are different very different to be
[ __ ] and like I said I'm not saying
that's good right no don't do that it's
just what's useful I don't we're not
talking about what's yeah I'm talking
about what what their desired outcome is
right what they're desired out right
his desired outcome he went about it in
the strongest possible yeah he was not a
good way of doing it he waged war
against something when it wasn't time
for that
the time to just talk about it and let
other people other people know had he
had a [ __ ] badass publication or
something that he could [ __ ] you know
a way where he could release media well
like I said nowadays although the thing
about it though is that nowadays if he
had grown up now I don't know if he
would have even had the necess
necessarily have had the same kind of
like anti-tech kind of thing I mean he
was a Luddite essentially like he didn't
really want anything to do with
technology he thought it was harmful
like across the board so I'm not really
sure if he would have gotten on board
with all of the technology even to the
point of like getting his message across
I don't know it's an interesting thought
experience he would have been in like
the [ __ ] the guys that made the Georgia
Guidestones he would have been in the
group that is doing like uh the great
reset where you're trying to stop oil
production and energy production and
because it's harming the Earth you'd
have been what do they call it
Extinction Rebellion he'd have been
about like that they believe that
John Smith said I'm guessing all that
time he was experimented on by MK Ultra
didn't help his disposition yeah we'll
get into that
quite sure
but uh for sure he volunteered for some
really [ __ ] up uh psychological
experiment so yeah we'll get into that
in a little bit and a lot of people do
kind of point out that maybe although I
will note that he um had problems prior
to that like as a kid
um but a lot of people point to that as
kind of like the the thing that [ __ ]
him up like the kind of like turning
point in his life or whatever I don't
think his Kaczynski was a joke okay he
wasn't a joke a lot of stuff he talked
about there's there's there's something
to those issues it's just the tech the
the strategy he decided to use was
improper strategy for the problem that
he was facing
the bombs [ __ ] worked against him not
for him which like I said that's what I
meant about him being like super
intelligent in some ways but then doing
like really dumb [ __ ] like that I mean
that's clearly a really dumb thing to do
like you have to think of like what what
consequences is this action going to
have I mean had he been able to think
that through trying to call attention to
himself but it it was it didn't help his
cause no not at all well and the weird
thing about it too is that he did this
[ __ ] which like I said you know I'm just
getting a very general thing right now
but he did this [ __ ] for what like 17
years before they caught him and it's
like he didn't really try to call
attention to himself or his cause all
that much until later you know what I
mean so I kind of feel like if he was
trying to do that then even if he wanted
to resort to you know not maybe
terrorism tactics but doing stuff like
you know uh I don't know just like
[ __ ] going someplace and like
sabotaging someplace that you know when
no one was there or something like that
and then leaving a message like you
would think that he would do more things
like that where he wasn't like actually
killing people that like I said most of
them didn't have anything to do with
anything that he was mad at you know he
just kind of like chose him about random
sort of
uh granther said was the Unabomber the
original incel debate and discuss no
um I don't think that's what that's what
no but there was like there was a tiny
aspect of that
um he did date women sometimes but not
all that much and there was a point
which I'll kind of get into but there
was a point too where he went through a
really weird thing where
he said that
um he went through a period where he's
like well I'll never touch a woman
unless I become a woman and then like he
had this really weird thing where he
actually even went to like a counselor
and say he wanted to start the process
for having a sex change weird and then
like but he like chickened out after a
while I didn't know about that yeah so
so he did have like some an incel
aspects and um you know and we'll kind
of get into that later because there was
like an incident that happened later on
like when he was working with his
brother and stuff like that all right so
um let me say hold on
I saw something else that I wanted to oh
David Jean said when the hell did Tom
get tatted up he's had those the whole
time yeah I guess just because for a
long time like you didn't wear
sleeveless but yeah you got those you
got those in the Army so you've had
those sensors since the 90s yeah so yeah
looking looking like a badass I would
not talk to him at the bar because he
probably beat my ass for not playing
you do look like you'd beat people's ass
yeah
yeah John Smith said personally I think
he just wanted to kill and maim the
cause was just the justification he used
on honestly I'm kind of leaning toward
that as well I mean I don't know the guy
but I don't know I kind of feel like
that's a that happens with a lot of
these type of dudes I kind of feel like
because he did say outright a few times
that the motive for doing what he was
doing was just Revenge you know what I'm
saying so I think he just wanted to kill
people and like he said he's you know
coming up with sometimes really
intelligent people can come up with
really good uh justifications for doing
what they wanted to do to start with so
there could be an aspect of that as well
uh Slash said you guys looked great all
costumed up thank you very much he says
happy belated Halloween again thank you
happy Halloween I know I had a really
good Halloween that was a that the
costume took a very long time to do but
I was happy how it turned out I did
actually did it twice because we went
out Saturday night and I did it and then
I did it again for the show
uh John Smith also there's a theory that
Ted is also the Zodiac but I think every
man in the 60s and 70s has been accused
yeah because I think um they did think
about it for a little while because he
did have some similarities but
um I think that they determined that he
was like in a different you know he was
in a different state or whatever like
they could determine that he was there
like when some of the zodiac crimes took
place so you know Murder Hornet says hey
everyone been a long day so I'm just
gonna lay my head down and listen
okay that's good uh granter says
question for Tom if Ted had gone on T
would the outcome be different uh no you
don't think so no I don't think so maybe
would it have been worse
been about to discuss he's been in
better shape we've been about to say
more bombs
that's what I was saying it's like it
probably would have made it worse if
anything maybe I'm more motivated yeah I
don't think he I don't think he needed
that I mean he was motivated enough as
it was you know not worried about
[ __ ] Ted
but that's what the show's about yeah so
you kind of at least need to not worry
about it I'm not worried about today
making more bombs he's locked up
yeah he better not be able to get more
bombs in there I always wonder though
like they still let him like um you know
correspond with people like outside in
the outside world and I'm like hopefully
they're checking all the [ __ ] letters
that he sends out you know saying make
sure he's not putting no [ __ ]
explosives he's trying to say anything
no well he's I don't know about nowadays
because I think like the newest thing
that I found was from a couple years
back but
I mean he is uh he's writes tons and
tons and tons of letters
he's he's a writer for sure
well when they when they went into his
cabin like when they caught him that
what they find like 40 000 pages of
stuff in there that he'd written down I
don't know let's get into the [ __ ] he
didn't really have that much else to do
you know yeah he didn't have no water
electricity get into the case yeah he
lived in a [ __ ] basically a log cabin
kind of it wasn't even I mean it was a
cabinet yeah it was a room yeah it was
like a shack it was like smaller than
this room yeah like I think it was 10 by
12 or 10 by 14 or something like that
which is about the size of like an
average bedroom yeah like in an average
house yeah but it was like a log cabin
sort of so I don't even remember what
the inside of it looked like but I
remember because I remember it was all
of the news I just remember them like
pulling them out him him looking like a
bomb yeah he's like a bomb living in a
damn shape it's crazy because when you
see pictures of him when he was young
when he was like a professor and stuff
like that he's a good looking dude and
he looked totally normal he went
backwards in time man he was trying to
live off the lad he's living off grid he
was yeah which like I said there's
nothing wrong with that I know a lot of
people wanted to I would not [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] that um you know we didn't
like make this this much scientific
progress so I could like go out there
and wipe my ass with a pine cone no
thank you he wasn't real good at it no
okay well they got a gun he did it for a
long time they got got yeah it still
wasn't that good at it there were guys
that just with hand tools and with just
like a couple of acres of land cut down
all the trees and then from the trees
they have enough wood to make a real
[ __ ] house okay that's how good some
dudes are with plumbing and everything
like something out of the [ __ ] late
1800s like pre-electricity era even with
the [ __ ] pumps pumping water and
everything in there they could even put
[ __ ]
um
water reservoirs on the top of the house
and pump water up to it and then they
can paint it black so you have hot water
coming out through your yeah you know
there's all kinds of stuff that dudes
can do just with hand tools if they have
the skill yeah I mean if you have the
time and the wherewithal you can do all
kind of [ __ ] you know what I mean but
it's like why I don't understand like
why you just want to make your life that
much harder when you don't really need
to you know what I mean yeah well like I
said if you have the skills you don't
need to live hard I mean [ __ ]
there there are people out there just
with regular hand tools can make a
two-story
house you know [ __ ] seven eight
bedrooms in it and [ __ ] you know a
garage and everything and like I said
people should totally be allowed to do
that like I don't have a problem with
people doing people be like yeah I'm out
I don't really like this whole cell
phone social media kind of [ __ ] I just
want to live out in the mountains
somewhere and like you know hunt and
fish and stuff go for it yeah don't
bother me none it's not my life is it
it's like I wouldn't want really want to
do that I don't think but I mean it
might be nice to do like for short
periods a lot of those beautiful
Victorian homes were mostly handmade
back in the 1800s people forget that
they did they were made with hand tools
yeah and a bunch of dudes working but
one guy could do that too they're if
they're good
they have time they're not in a hurry
they usually build a house to live in
while they're building the other house
yeah John Smith said I'm guessing they
let him correspond so the FBI knows who
to keep an eye on yeah I never thought
of that yeah I guess probably they are
uh lion X Warrior said thank you for
covering this very interesting topic
well you're very welcome like I said I'm
amazed that we hadn't covered this
already because I could have sworn what
we had but oh well he goes laughing at
my pine cone thing well
like I said I'm just saying that look I
get that he had some points about like
technology overreach and [ __ ] like that
and that's true all right but I don't
know man I would want to go back I
wouldn't want to go back to like
pre-industrial Revolution I wouldn't
want to go back to like before there was
you know running water and vaccines and
electricity and [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's
like people died really young back then
like they died of a really easily
preventable diseases it's like all the
food had gross ass [ __ ] in it it's like
I don't electricity smells a lot of
problems no thanks
electricity solves a lot of problems
especially in a kitchen
things like immersion blenders and
[ __ ] little bitty toaster ovens
toasters
in a electric hot plates
mixers
you know electricity is [ __ ] critical
yeah it saves a lot it's very
labor-saving
yeah you had some [ __ ] hand cranked
mixed mixers but
no you want an immersion blenders you
want Little electric ovens and [ __ ]
hot plates and you want little things
made out of the like you want the little
things that electricity could do
well the thing about it was that I kind
of feel like one of his main things that
he was always harping on was that he
thought I mean he wanted to go back it
seemed like from what he was saying he
wanted to go back to like pre-industrial
Revolution he's like he's like you know
um the Advent of the Industrial
Revolution you know uh and all this
technology and progress and stuff like
that has actually made people more
[ __ ] up and unhappier and has them
doing like useless Pursuits like
watching sports teams and like watching
entertainment and stuff like that I'm
like but the whole point of
technological technological progress at
least to a degree is to give people more
leisure time so they can do [ __ ] that
they want to do instead of being because
prior to the Industrial Revolution it's
like you had to like doing laundry for
example was like a one or two day Affair
it was just like a whole you had to do
everything by hand you had to scrape
everything you know what I mean it's
like why the [ __ ] would you want to go
back to that no thanks because he
doesn't know about it I mean you can if
you want I'm not stopping you like if
you want to go back and do that you have
a good time okay you just go in the
woods and go do your laundry in a creek
and like have the hole and like is it
doing they were hand washing laundry all
the way up to the 30s yeah and you could
do it in the 40s too and yeah people in
the 50s had washing laundry people
[ __ ] did it in the 80s I remember
yeah and people that didn't have any
[ __ ] money like students and
everything well something more that day
you wore that [ __ ] in the shower I've
done that I washed it while it was on
I've watched it in the shower with you
folding up
one one clothing [ __ ] at a time well
now turn it back up now sometimes I have
to hand wash stuff that can't go in the
washing machine because sometimes
because you know I don't have like I'm
not taking the [ __ ] to be dry cleaned or
anything like that so sometimes I'll
kind of like hand wash things like that
or stuff that's like real delicate
um you know and even that's a pain so I
can't even imagine like doing all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah remember I said like
before I saw that uh short on MST which
I think was from the 30s and they were
talking about how people used to wash
their clothes like hand wash their
clothes and gasoline yes yeah and
they're and they were trying to it's
like hey don't blow yourself up
for people who are worried about it
wasn't the same gasoline yeah I mean it
was a different thing I mean it was
still flammable yeah though you know
what I mean didn't have any detergents
in it and all kinds of other anti-knock
stuff gasoline used to be a lot more
mild you'd be able to put it on you put
it in your hair maybe people used
gasoline his hair paw made had a lot of
oil in it too
weird then they're all smoking
well they think the [ __ ] gasoline I
think the gasoline would evaporate I
hope so because like I said otherwise
you're blowing your [ __ ] head out
yeah but they were trying to kill lice
and parasites and [ __ ] which again it
worked
yeah but it's like why the [ __ ] would
people want to have to do that it's like
you know we have shampoo and [ __ ] now
it's like you know what I mean we don't
have to put gasoline in our hair to kill
them there was something different back
then they got lice
it had some different different [ __ ]
living I mean people still get lice but
usually very rare but yeah it's I don't
know I don't think it's very common now
if anybody that has like little kids and
because I remember like when I was a
little kid like in the 70s and 80s every
now and then they'd have somebody come
in and do like a lice check every now
and then they would find one kid but not
that often and that was like in the 70s
and 80s and usually you know it's a kid
from like a poorer neighborhood or
something like that because like I said
you know
yeah but I don't know how common it is
now I guess because I don't have you
know I don't have any kids just back in
the day living conditions were a lot
worse and hygiene wasn't as good
yeah that's what I mean lice yeah
so yeah that's another thing it's like
look the world is trying to kill you
nature is trying to kill you not trying
to kill you like you know it's not evil
outright but it's just it doesn't care
about you you know what I mean it was
also more um
rural back then
so neighborhoods were closer to the
Woods and Woods were really woods they
went back [ __ ] dozens and hundreds of
miles in some places
so you were on the edge of [ __ ] the
forest so I imagine
it was easier for lice to get you yeah
there are more of them probably
I don't know I remember the way
Mississippi was in the 70s
nothing like that
but maybe it was back in the 20s and 30s
yeah I don't know why they probably was
yeah I imagine probably was well like
you said it's probably more Rural and
they didn't really have it's like being
out in the Amazon I mean maybe they were
all taking a bath in the same water and
it's like you know what I mean they were
probably like running around they're not
taking a bathroom not taking a bath very
often sure well that's one thing would
lead to the other if you had to take a
bath with like everybody's in the same
water because I know that that happened
but
grafter said didn't Dennis Raiders Fame
irritate the Unabomber I seem to recall
Ted wrote a Manifesto talking on BTK did
he really I didn't find that but it's
like yeah we're gonna have to look that
up because that would be super funny
uh David June thank you very much for
the Super Chat said tell my friend
Gandalf to watch Doctor sleep and not to
be such a lightweight when it comes to
Blazing okay
watch Doctor I sleep God damn it
yeah Dr sleep is good
especially the uh
director's cut
director's Cuts better than a theatrical
cut
yes maybe had a lot of extra [ __ ] in
there a lot more of a complete story
John Smith said technology has solved a
few problems if he stood on a rusty nail
on Monday people were coming to your
funeral on Wednesday exactly that's what
I mean it's like
back in the day you know people would
get a [ __ ] cold or some [ __ ] or
measles and they would die from that
[ __ ] so no thanks I don't want to go
back to that uh Richard Brown said have
you covered the Yorkshire Ripper case on
this channel we did but it was a very
long time ago I don't even remember what
episode it was
probably pre 100 I want to say before we
were even on camera when it was just
audio Maybe
but I'm pretty sure we covered that I'm
pretty sure
I like to do like a lot of British uh
you know because I lived in the UK for a
little while like back in the 90s so I
did Cover like a Yorkshire Ripper I
think we did the Moore's murders but
that might have been on like a killer
couples show
and we did some other stuff as well so
uh Camp guy said my daughter used to get
lice it drove my wife crazy
yeah that's the thing it's like I don't
know now it's making my head itch now
that we're talking about it
you know what I mean it's just like when
you start talking about spiders like
you're just kind of like no it doesn't
bother me yeah well probably because you
weren't listening no
that's probably why I was listening I
just don't get that John Smith said the
myth that lice would only live in clean
hair was just propaganda put out by the
smelly kids moms
yeah I heard that I actually heard that
as well that's like oh well no it's only
if your hair is really clean they don't
even like dirty hair I'm like I don't
think I believe that oh nice to get into
anybody yeah I don't think like I don't
think lights are particular they're just
like oh it's hair okay that'll work you
know they're not rolled they're not real
picky
um all right so a couple shout outs that
I have I think I said this one before
but I wanted to make sure to do it on
the main show like I usually do but we
have a new Patron our first one in a
long time
and their name is master of dungeons
okay so thank you very much master of
dungeons our newest Patron in I don't
even remember when the last one why
don't we talk about those yeah I'm gonna
do that too I'm gonna do that just you
know I have I have it like right there I
have everything written down
everything's organized managing it I'm
not gonna manage well well yeah I got
like all this okay
all right he acts like I don't have a
big loss
[Laughter]
but yeah we just got a package like uh
an hour ago actually from Louis friend
of the show who sent us to Kick-Ass
movies one of which is
tombstone
with Kurt Russell the Crustle and Val
Kilmer which is good because I I love
this movie but I haven't seen it in a
really really long time
and also
sent us Splatoon
the collector's edition so thank you
very much Louie so I guess these are
going to be the two movies that we're
gonna do for next week's Matt hey so
that's all sorted out we haven't done
platoon have we we did um no we didn't
we did um what was the other one what's
a we did Full Metal Jacket that was what
I was thinking of the Stanley Cooper
coin but we haven't done uh platoon
because that's Oliver Stone right yeah
all right so those we'll probably do
those for the next matinee
uh DJ Maniac said uh did you start on
that book I sent you yet I've already
finished it and started another I'm
gonna start reading it probably tomorrow
or Friday because I think I'm putting up
a review of it
um on Monday there should be a review of
it going up on Monday which means that
either tomorrow or Friday I'll start
reading it because usually I read them
Thursday Friday or over the weekend and
then like I usually record a review of
them
been that but that's the next one on my
list uh and also somebody recommended
the book The Black farm and I bought
that one as well I think it was only
three dollars so I'm gonna do that one
on the 14th I think so I haven't read
that one yet either but yeah it's I'm
gonna read it
in a in a day or two like I'm gonna get
started on it so did you like it or did
you mean I said it's a fast read oh okay
well that's good that's good so it'll
probably be a couple days then I'll get
it read all right so are we ready to
start on this on the [ __ ] now I've been
waiting for you to start have you really
yeah I'm here don't be a smartass I'm uh
I'm answering questions okay Danny Rolex
said Ted had some pretty good off-grid
cabin making skills yeah I think I
thought that him and his brother had had
built that cabin but like I said it's
not it's not a big cabin it was just
like a room essentially that's like I
told you those [ __ ] Victorian [ __ ]
Mansions were all built off grid
pre-electricity with hand tools most of
them most that's it you could do a lot
better they weren't that good
yeah I mean to be honest it's like you
know I don't mean to cast aspersions on
anybody's uh house building cabin
building skills but
it basically just kind of looked like a
shack you know yeah you they got [ __ ]
too little Indonesian looking guys
they're just with a couple of little
blades and little
it's like a stick with a [ __ ] flat
blade on the end of it
can go out into the into the [ __ ]
jungle where they live and build a
[ __ ] Paradise looking house just out
of the dirt they're [ __ ] digging it
out of the dirt and making mud and
feeling it full of water make a swimming
pool and
making all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] out of bamboo and making bamboo
roof for it and beautiful you know you
see it on YouTube
there's looks like
it's like something you paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars for and they just
made it out of stuff that was right
there in the juggle
which is pretty awesome a couple of had
tools yeah two little Indonesian guys
how long did it take them did they say a
couple days
a couple days they show it happen in
fast motion yeah you know well obviously
you can't wear it right you can't watch
a video that's two days long and then
they pipe they pipe [ __ ] water in and
there'll be pools outside and pools
inside and you know there's a whole
water system and everything
for the houses you know looks cool
that seems like a good skill set to have
yeah
they're digging down into the ground
making underground uh you know
rooms
tunnels and stuff and it's all decorated
the walls are all decorated they'll with
the little blades they'll make like
columns and places where candles can go
and sconces yeah little alcoves and
stuff and uh they'll [ __ ] cut little
statues into the walls and [ __ ]
beautiful you know you could live in
there that's badass yeah
maybe they could build me a house
underground somewhere yeah I don't know
if it's still if if most of that [ __ ]
doesn't look like it would last you'd
have to go in there and treat it yeah
with something to keep the sand from
falling
but uh but you could do that you know
it's a shellac day shellac it or
something
Danny Rollings that I heard Ted tried to
replicate pot Ingalls cabin from Little
House on the Prairie
I think even was nicer and bigger
there's at least there's even had like a
loft I don't think he's had a loft
yeah granther said he had been estranged
from his brother for decades but his
brother still recognized his nutty
writings yeah I think it was um like I
said his sister-in-law kind of thought
that the manifesto kind of sounded like
him too and then I think it was in
particular like a couple specific turns
of phrase that he used and
um his brother's wife was just kind of
like man that sounds just like your
brother even though she'd never met him
but she'd read some of his letters and
stuff she said man that sounds just like
your brother and like and the brother
was like no it couldn't be but then he
started reading stuff and he was like oh
maybe it might be but yeah
yeah that was it was something like um
you can't what did he say you can't eat
your cake and have it too I think that
was one of the phrases where usually
it's like you know you can't have your
cake and eat it too but he would say it
like reversed and that was like a really
specific thing that he always said and
he recognized that like in the manifesto
and he was like oh oh I don't think that
was the only thing but that was one of
the things that stuck out to him I think
um what what's up what are you gonna do
about it oh my God
[Music]
she's gonna go tear those books up now
all right so we're talking about today
Dr Theodore Ted Kaczynski
they actually call him the Unabomber I
had forgotten about this but they called
him the Unabomber because before they
caught him uh it was supposed to be like
an acronym for University and Airline
bomber so it was u-n-a-b-o-m you know I
mean because most of his targets were uh
at universities or you know heads of
Airlines and stuff like that
so uh mostly known as a mathematician
like before he started blowing stuff up
but um yeah it did I think 17 years uh
was his reign of terror before they
actually caught him uh of all the bombs
that he sent
um three people died and uh 23 others
were injured
so he was born in 1942 in Chicago
uh his parents were second generation uh
polish Americans
now one thing that happened very early
like when he was still a baby that may
have contributed I don't know if this
contributed but some people have pointed
this out
um so he got some kind of like rash or
hives or something like that when he was
six months old
so he got taken to the hospital and they
put him in isolation like nobody was
allowed to come in and see him because
they didn't know what it was I guess and
they kind of kept him in there like that
for eight months
now after he came out of the hospital
his mom said that um that he was healthy
like he was okay but was unresponsive so
I thought that was like kind of
interesting that that was like a very
early experience that he had I don't
know if it had anything to do with
something like some [ __ ] to happen later
on
so when he was in fifth grade they did
an IQ test on him his measured IQ at
that time was
167. you're smart which yeah that's like
super genius that's super genius it's
smarter me
that's smarter than most people that's
smarter than pretty much everybody uh
that's up there that's up there with
like Stephen Hawking level that's like
Stephen Hawk
so um so since he scored so high on the
IQ test in fifth grade they actually
allowed him to skip sixth grade and go
right to seventh
now he later described this as being
like a big turning point in his life
because and I've seen this happen
because I went to school with a kid who
skipped a grade or two
and
um
it's kind of shitty because they don't
you know that they're really smart and
they can do all the schoolwork and
everything like that but they're not
like emotionally mature enough to like
hang with older kids and a lot of times
too you know obviously they're
physically smaller and like you know
they're younger so sometimes the older
kids because kids are [ __ ] you know
uh so they're gonna pick on him and
that's pretty much what happened to him
like he had a lot of bullying and [ __ ]
like that because he was much smaller
than the other kids and younger and
stuff like that
so he I don't know if he developed this
or if he always had this but he did kind
of have um he was very very introverted
he was like afraid of other people he
was also afraid of buildings which okay
um and he would basically like he would
go out and play with kids but he'd be
like over here next to him like playing
on his own like and wouldn't talk to
them or like interact with them in any
way
um you know he was kind of a person and
I was like I don't want to like make
this sound too weird because I used to
do this too but
um but like when guests would come to
your house or whatever like he'd go up
and hide like in the attic and I'm like
that's not that weird though because I
used to do that too I'm like oh my God
people gross and then like I'd go like
him in the other room you know what I
mean but yeah he used to do that kind of
stuff he didn't really like uh being
around people at all he was very much a
loner
um now his mom got really really worried
about this like I said he was only in
you know he was maybe like 12 or 13 at
this point 11 12 13 somewhere in there
his mom got really worried about him
uh that he wasn't really like making any
friends or you know learning any social
skills or anything so she was going to
enter him it's you know the very famous
uh child child psychologist whatever uh
Bruno battleheim he was doing a study
for autistic children around this time
and she was actually going to enter him
in that but they never but she never got
around to it
so that went on for a little while he
eventually went to high school and he
was like
I mean he was just like Miles and Miles
like ahead of everybody else like
particularly like his first year of high
school they said the math was too easy
for him
um and he basically became really
obsessed with mathematics around this
time and he would like lock himself in
his room and like do all these
differential equations and that kind of
stuff and like I said didn't really hang
out with people or socialize with them
didn't really have any social skills now
um like I said he was so far ahead of
everybody else like they put him in an
advanced math class but that still
wasn't Advanced enough for him
so they basically let him skip 11th
grade also
and then
um after that like he took some summer
school like uh you know for English and
some other things so they let him
graduate early like he actually
graduated from high school when he was
15.
and because
um of his you know Sterling academic
record and how intelligent he was they
actually encouraged him to apply to
Harvard and he was accepted
um he got accepted when he was 16 and
that was he started going there in Fall
of 1958. I believe he also got a full
scholarship which is uh amazing but like
I said because he was so intelligent and
because he'd done so well in mathematics
they thought you know he's gonna be he's
gonna do like really well which he did
for a time and in a way like I think
that one of the things that's really
kind of tragic about this story is that
he was so smart and he was so good at
what he did that
it seemed like he pissed it all away
like he could have like made something
of himself you know what I mean it's
like like I said look at what look at
Stephen Hawking for Christ's sake it's
like why he could have been another
Stephen Hawking it's like why why did he
just have to blow people up it's like he
just [ __ ] wasted it I don't know that
made me mad he came up with his own
reasons why he had to do it I know but
it's like that just made me mad because
it just seemed like a waste I'm like
it's so rare that like somebody of that
intellect like comes along you could
have done something good with that but
he just didn't he just what poke pissed
it away
she's just like crying the whole time oh
there's nothing what oh my goodness
[Laughter]
she doesn't like it it's very upsetting
for her
um so yeah so this is the study that
we're uh that we were talking about
earlier
so while he was at Harvard
there was
um like a psychologist psychiatrist
named Dr Henry Murray and he was
supposedly like an expert on what this
what they call stress interviews
no and so they were doing he was doing
um a multi-year like personality study
and he was looking for volunteers for
that and you know a lot of college
students background that's for extra
money like they would volunteer for
these kind of studies and so Ted and
like I think like about a couple dozen
other people like also volunteered for
maybe 21 other people I think if I
remember correctly
so basically what they said now they
think that this study was probably
funded by the CIA which is where the
whole MK Ultra thing uh came along like
it was kind of like a mind control type
of thing and a lot of people think that
this particular uh event or actually it
wasn't just one event it was like a
three year because he would go back like
every so often and like they would do it
again you know what I mean
um was maybe like the Catalyst for for
what ended up happening you know what
I'm saying
so what they would do like with this
study they would go in and they would
basically say
um what the study was or what they were
doing was well we want everybody to
that's in the study we want you to write
an essay about what your personal
philosophy of life is like what your
beliefs are or whatever so they wanted
everybody to write an essay about that
now so they turned them all in but then
what ended up happening was the people
that we're doing this study
they would take the essays that
everybody wrote and then they would put
the subjects like in a room like with
they would strap you to a chair they put
like electrodes on you that would
monitor like your physiological
reactions and then they'd like shine
lights in your face and there'd be like
a two-way mirrors they could watch you
and everything and then they would start
like berating you and like belittling
you and like making fun of your beliefs
and making fun of your philosophies and
your you know what I mean they would
just kind of like
take what you had written and like throw
it back in your face like in the
cruelest way possible and they would
just like keep doing that and they would
just keep at you and keep at you and
keep at you and then not only that they
would do that but then like at the next
sessions they would do that but then
they would show you
um recordings of the past sessions and
they would show you your own facial
expressions like back at you so like you
could see how [ __ ] angry you were
getting and how frustrated you were
getting that's so weird and they were
trying to like well they wanted to see
like obviously because if you do like a
psychological study you're not supposed
to tell you have to tell them kind of
that it's about something else because
otherwise it'll ruin you know whatever
if people know what it is you're
studying then it'll ruin the outcome or
whatever so
um so obviously they didn't tell them
that that's what the study was about but
I think what they were studying was some
kind of they wanted to see basically how
much it would take to like
psychologically just like break someone
down is what they were essentially
trying to test
wanted to know that well like I said a
lot of people said that this might have
been part of MK Ultra because they think
maybe the CIA had something to do with
like funding this study
um like I said this was back in the like
late 50s early 60s I do not think this
test would be allowed and nowadays
because of ethical standards but like
back then
um yeah I don't I mean as far as I as
far as I'm aware um they wouldn't let
they wouldn't allow you to do this study
nowadays but you know there's a lot of
psychological studies they did back in
the 50s and 60s that they would not let
you do that they would not let you do
nowadays because they're really really
unethical and this definitely seems
unethical because it was basically like
I said it wasn't constantly you would
come in
um I kind of feel like it was like maybe
once a week or twice a week or something
like that and you would come in like for
a few hours and they would do like
sessions but it was over a long period
was like over three years like you would
come back every so often like they paid
you for it you know or whatever but they
would just keep doing it and I guess
they wanted to see and I'd actually kind
of be curious to know what happened
because we know what happened with Ted
Kaczynski but um I'd kind of be curious
to know what happened to like the other
20 odd people in the study like were
they [ __ ] up forever too or was it
just Ted you know what I mean and I'm
not saying I know it's very very
simplistic to say oh this is what caused
his because obvious he had you know
um some social awkwardness and like some
problems before this time like he was
already super introverted he was already
he'd already been bullied he'd already
had all these other things but this
clearly did not help and this might have
kind of been like the breaking point you
know what I'm saying like this
experience that he went through
put you out
look at her face she's like what what
yeah you're in trouble
John Smith said is Ted a super villain
he does kind of strike me as somebody
that's like a super villain you know
what I mean
but uh but yeah I mean apparently they
did before they even started the test
and this is another usual thing they
that they do with this kind of
psychological testing is that they'll do
um you know kind of like an evaluation
of all the subjects like beforehand to
make sure that you're not getting any
like you know crazy people in there or
anything like that they want to make
sure that everybody's fine and like
emotionally stable and everything and
they said that Kaczynski seemed
emotionally stable before the study
started so
you know it is so it's possible that
this could have been like kind of uh a
big thing that
contributed maybe to his
hostility I guess later on you know what
I mean but I don't think that
I mean if it was just the study that did
it then obviously everyone that was in
the study would have like freaked out
and become super villains but I think
because of the particular way that Ted
was
um you know it was just kind of like a
combination of factors that's kind of
what I think
uh so basically
uh Ted graduated from Harvard in 1962.
and then he went to uh I think he got a
ba and then he went to the University of
Michigan and then he got a masters there
and a doctoral degree in mathematics and
that was in 1964 1967. now um he hadn't
actually wanted University of Michigan
was actually not his first choice for
doing his uh doctoral degree but uh he
actually applied to UC Berkeley and
University of Chicago and he actually
got into both places but
um he actually ended up going to um
because they offered him a teaching
position and financial aid like he got
like a big Grant package like it was
like uh the equivalent to like twenty
one thousand dollars a year
um and they gave him like a job there
like a teaching post which the other two
colleges didn't offer so he's like okay
well that's obviously the best deal so
that's where he went so his whole
specialty like while he was in school
was um I guess it's called like
geometric function Theory please don't
ask me to explain it I'm not really a
math person so you know what I mean uh
and apparently like his professors there
were like thought he was amazing and
it's like he even
I mean he even solved like some
equations like his professors like
couldn't figure out and [ __ ] like that
so he was like way ahead of the curve on
the on the stuff you know what I mean
now basically uh he ended up writing
like a dissertation that um you know got
huge like all of the um everybody that
read it was just like oh my God this is
like one of the coolest things like even
though probably only about a dozen
people in the United States would
probably even understand it but you know
it's amazing anyway
so uh 1967 he actually won uh a prize
like at the University of Michigan uh
which was like gave him the prize for
like the best dissertation in
mathematics that year
uh and he also got a National Science
Foundation fellowship and actually
taught uh for three years and published
some articles and things like that
um so you know he was kind of way up in
Academia he would have like I said he
would have been
like Stephen Hawking or somebody like
that had he continued on this course uh
you know but obviously we know that
that's not what happened
now after he graduated he actually ended
up becoming an assistant professor of
mathematics at UC Berkeley which like I
said he had applied there and gotten in
before but he ended up graduating from
um because of various reasons so he
ended up teaching some undergraduate
courses there in calculus and geometry
um but he was only there for I believe
like a year or two
now that's the thing though everybody
talked about he was brilliant like a
brilliant mind but again very very
socially awkward and his students gave
him like really low rankings they said
you know he basically comes in he
mumbles
um you know he's very he's always like
stuttering over his words it's like when
we try to go because you know how
professors and they have like um you
know office hours like students can go
in after hours and like ask them
questions and stuff and it's like we
couldn't really do that like he would
always just like not be in the office or
he would just ignore us like if we went
there so he wasn't real
comfortable in a teaching environment
and the students could kind of see that
so they gave him like really really low
ratings
so in 1969 he was only 26 years old and
he quit without really giving anyone a
reason why
um and you know they were kind of bummed
out about it because they said you know
he was very like all of his Publications
were like really impressive it seemed
like he was on track uh to be very very
high up like a very Advanced member of
The Faculty but he just quit and didn't
really tell anybody about why he quit
but like I said I imagine it was
probably because
um he wasn't real comfortable teaching
because he wasn't really good with
people
so 1971 in the summer uh Ted moved back
to his parents house in Lombard Illinois
and he lived there for a couple of years
just kind of like doing odd jobs and
[ __ ] like that
two years after that uh he moved into
the famous cabin now he had built it um
Wikipedia said he built it himself but I
saw somewhere else that he built it him
and his brother built it like it was
because him and his brother like owned
this piece of land you know what I mean
um and so in Montana where they where he
had built the thing on there
so basically he just wanted to go back
to Nature and live like a simple life
like Off the Grid you know um so the
cabin didn't have any electricity it
didn't have any running water
um and like I said he worked odd jobs
around his family also gave him money
which he would later use to essentially
like buy [ __ ] for making bombs and stuff
which his family obviously did not know
about
now in 1978 he actually went and worked
with his dad and his brother for a
little while like at a factory uh that
made foam rubber or something but um his
brother ended up having to fire him
because Ted was harassing a female
supervisor uh who he had dated briefly
like they had dated they'd broken up and
then then he just kept like [ __ ] with
her and harassing her and stuff like
that and it got so bad that eventually
his brother was like bro you know you
you can't stay here so he told him to
leave
so because Ted was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and decided he was gonna go and live out
in the middle of nowhere in his cabin
he wanted to become completely
self-sufficient
so he started teaching himself how to
track animals how to find like edible
plants how to you know just build things
that you would need like out in the
woods
but he's basically out there for a
little while and then he starts to
notice that the area around where his
cabin is is getting destroyed by you
know real estate development and
Industrial Development and things like
that and it's starting to piss him off
because he wants to be like out in
nature you know what I mean
so because he was so angry at all of
this industrialization of the Wilderness
as he saw it he started doing like I
mentioned before he started doing like
sabotaging their [ __ ] you know what I
mean like he's like if somebody was
building a road he'd try to go and [ __ ]
it up or you know something like that
like no he wasn't hurting anybody at
first he was just trying to make enough
trouble for them that they would like go
away and not build roads and roll his
[ __ ] and whatever
um but yeah they said the one thing
though that made him decide that he was
gonna go Whole Hog on the thing and
start blowing people up was that
um he goes out for a walk one day in one
of his favorite spots and then discovers
that the spot had been essentially like
paved over you know what I mean paved
Paradise and put up a parking lot as
they say in the song uh he went out and
walk and saw that and it just that was
like the last straw the straw that broke
the camel's back he's like well okay I'm
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] some [ __ ] up now
so after that he starts getting into
Manifesto mode let's call it that
so he starts reading I mean he spent a
lot of time at like the local library uh
you know reading pretty much everything
sociology political philosophy stuff
like that he was real into a guy named
uh Jacques elul I guess is how you
pronounce his last name who is a
Christian Anarchist uh and he also kind
of like got real into doing sabotage and
[ __ ] like that
and basically he came to the conclusion
and we've kind of talked about this a
little bit earlier that well the only
way to fight back against industrial
civilization is with violence
um he didn't think that it was possible
that anything could be reformed at this
stage and he said basically I mean
basically what he was saying was that we
have to like just burn it all down
that's what he was saying like it has to
be like a violent collapse
um and that's the only way that we're
gonna be able to like come back and be
like happy people again because his
whole thing like I said he was kind of
like a neoluddite what they would call
um his whole thing was that he thought
that the Advent of Technology
was making people screwed up and
unhappier because they were essentially
getting farther and farther away from
like a state of nature or from the way
that people used to live like back in
caveman days he thought that people
would be happier
living like they evolve to
um without any of the modern
technological things because he just
thought that was making things more
complicated and it was making people
unhappy and it was making people
um do things that were useless or were
not goal directed you know like I feel
like that's kind of what he was getting
at
whoops I'm just having like uh [ __ ] like
popping up all right
in my face and I can't like really see
what's going on the [ __ ] pop up in your
face yeah familiar laughing [ __ ] pop up
in your face it's emails okay all right
it's email I was thinking of sexual
well of course you're always thinking
that you're popping up in your face
in your feet John Smith said so is Ted
The Lorax a little bit I I kind of feel
like maybe he read that as a kid and
it's just kind of like but yeah so
like I said I kind of feel like this is
where the intelligence started shading
over into
and you have to think this is way before
the Advent of the internet this is where
when he was writing this stuff this was
like the 70s right like the late 70s and
he starts getting just into
you know I don't know I just kind of
feel like he got into a thing where it's
like oh nowadays it's like there's too
much too much technology and it's
screwing people up we're not supposed to
live like this
and everybody would be happier like
society would work better if we didn't
have all this other stuff going on which
like I said I don't really agree with
that like I see where he was coming from
like some of the [ __ ] that he says
but it was a pre-industrial societies
did not work well at all
they just didn't
all you gotta do is just look at the
Maya that's what I'm saying yeah it's
like have you
I kind of feel like Indians their [ __ ]
didn't work too well they burned down
whole [ __ ] Forest
and then they were like oh what's up
yeah where'd it go yeah look at Easter
Islands look what happened there
but that well that's what I mean it's
like
I feel yeah I feel like he had like a
big blind spot yeah in that area you
know what I'm saying and I'm not saying
oh always like technological progress is
always good obviously it's not
um or technological innovation is always
good there's always a dark side and a
light side to everything like sometimes
you know this [ __ ] is good but sometimes
it's you know there's bad [ __ ] too like
I said but really only industrial
civilizations have a concept of concert
of of conservation right and an ecology
back in Rome had no concept of that
they'd go into Africa and kill every
[ __ ] lion they found
yeah they did it didn't even occur to
them yeah they just sent them all to the
Adam Arena because they were worth money
they they [ __ ] were lucky to have
lions
because
we're lucky that the Romans didn't have
them all wiped out in the [ __ ] Arena
yeah it's almost like it was something
that didn't occur to them they were just
kind of like oh well they're there so we
just got to use them it's like it never
really occurred to them that there
wouldn't be any more or there was a
finite number yeah they didn't think it
like they didn't just didn't think like
that yeah no concept of it so in that
way it's like I kind of feel like even
even though some people might say oh Ted
Kaczynski he was almost like an
environmentalist not really I just kind
of feel like it was a different he was
coming at it from a different thing yeah
he didn't like it that nature was being
industrialized or paved over which yeah
like a lot of people don't like that but
I don't know if he was
I don't know if you really thought
through like what that would entail like
everyone going back and living like that
like now now that the world is like so
much more populous I just I don't know
how that would work out it couldn't work
out that's what I'm saying I have
Industrial Assembly you have to have
industrial technology to participate in
this kind of sustain this population you
have to have power
power production is what produces
fertilizer and food uh food production
uh without power you couldn't produce
the food that you have now without that
food
within two years the population would
collapse
oh yeah yeah that's what I mean so
that's why it's these people talking
about trying to get rid of fossil fuels
they're [ __ ] tripping they're
tripping because that's where
first of all production of fossil fuels
where fertilizer comes from now
fertilizer is what's help helps us
[ __ ] have these [ __ ] high
population numbers and then all the farm
equipment is sucking gasoline and
[ __ ] diesel powered you couldn't do
it by hand or horses uh you could but it
would
your your production rates will go way
down what you're talking about is
[ __ ] starving out millions and
millions of people on the planet if you
get rid of
what they're calling fossil fuel I'm not
convinced that it has anything to do
with fossils I've
there's a lot of scientists that say
wait [ __ ]
there's [ __ ] hydrocarbons on [ __ ]
the surface of Titan that's [ __ ] oil
there's never been any life on Titan
pressure heat hydrogen and carbon makes
hydrocarbons
you know I think it's everywhere every
planets have it or most planets have it
let's just soot and hydrogen [ __ ]
near the core of the planet making oil
that's all it is
you don't even need life to have it
but it's just it's a common common
[ __ ] thing in in planets
but what I'm saying is that
I think any extreme like this is always
going to like get you into trouble
because it's like you know I'm not
saying that unregulated like unmitigated
like technological Advance that's not
good either because that can cause
pollution that can cause like other
unintended consequences maybe but going
back before we had any of that that's
not going to solve anything either you
know what I mean I just kind of feel
like you have to just keep
you just have to keep trying to strike a
balance yeah anybody who's [ __ ]
talking about going backwards in time
when it comes to technology talking
about these are malthusians people that
believed in mouth those and mouth those
was [ __ ] old writer and he believed
it that the planet could only [ __ ]
hold a million people if there's any
more than that and they'd all die or a
couple million people I remember exactly
what he said
every time some
some pseudo-intellectual or scientist of
their era comes up with a number a
carrying number for the planet it's
always proven wrong because he's not a
factor in malthos didn't factor in
modern [ __ ] agricultural technology
he didn't know anything about that
right the paradigms change that's why I
don't worry too much about and that's
another reason too and I've said this on
other shows that I don't really like to
make predictions about like what will
happen in the future oh it's gonna go
like this or it's gonna it's nobody
knows it's like nobody knows I mean some
people might get it right by accident
but nobody knows because there's too
many factors the general scientists
always get the future wrong always just
look at backwards in time and look at
what they're saying is going to be
around 50 years from now like you go
back to the [ __ ] early 1900s and see
what they're saying is going to be
around in the 1950s and they're going to
say it's [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] Zeppelins
with wings this is going to be around
the 1950s powered by horses you know
they didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about well like said they were
products of their time like they they
only had I mean people only have so like
limited imagination right and so you can
only imagine things essentially like
within the parameters of what your time
is what's possible in your time and
maybe a little bit outside of that but
not much farther out and then you have
some people who get arrogant well this
is the modern era we can predict what
will happen no you can't when I was a
kid there was no way of foreseeing the
internet and what the internet would do
to the economy there is no way
well and that's what and the thing about
it too it's like it's interesting if you
even go back I mean even something dumb
you know what I mean like it doesn't
mean it's not dumb but I mean something
that's as seemingly trivial maybe that's
what I meant to say about
um what was that show that we were
watching like the the food that made
America or whatever like
um it's yeah don't yell don't yell at
her because that's a lot more she's
stuck in being crazy stuff I know but
she'll get bored like if you you know
okay she's gone no no she's behind you
all right just let her pull them out
it's fine
she's yelling too much I know but what
is it you want
[Laughter]
can you guys hear her it's like so funny
she's like yeah now she's up here on the
desk and then she's like well now I'm
gonna eat your camera and I'm gonna lick
your keyboard and all this other stuff
but um but even that like that food that
made America or whatever it's it's
amazing how much like stupid little
details stupid little contingencies like
change the course of entire Industries
you know what I mean it's just kind of
like oh this guy didn't file the right
patents at the right time so this other
guy came in and this whole other thing
happened that wouldn't have happened had
this guy's [ __ ] not not like falling
behind the desk or some [ __ ] like that
so it's like always just little
unpredictable [ __ ] like that and that
could it seems like nothing but it's
like a butterfly effect and it just
Alters the course of history and there's
no way you can predict every little tiny
thing like that no and here's nothing
people know that television came out in
the 50s
there it almost came out in the 30s
though and that's something that a lot
of people don't understand they were
they [ __ ] basically could have yeah
there was a show about that we we
watched this the other day yeah it
almost came out in the 30s but World War
II happened which prevented it yeah and
they weren't able to do it until the war
was over so then then yeah see I didn't
I didn't even know that yeah they had it
in the 30s
yeah they were working on it they had it
it was working like it wasn't great like
it was very primitive but it worked it
wasn't there yeah because everybody was
at War so they said well wait yeah I
think like as soon as they kind of got
they're like woohoo we got it to work
and then like war broke out and they're
like well [ __ ] yeah and then like it
just went under like foreign
yeah because they were you know people
had other priorities yeah but see that's
what I would have been very different
had it come out in the 30s right that's
like something you never could have
predicted and yeah like I said look at
that's why I think people are so
fascinated by fiction that's like
alternate history and things like that
because sometimes it's just like a tiny
tiny little detail like that and it just
kind of like changes everything yeah you
know I mean like had this one little
tiny thing not happened like things
would have gone off in a completely
different direction so there's just too
much of that the world especially
nowadays is way too complex so I don't
think anyone can reliably predict maybe
you can like five years down the road
maybe but any farther than that I don't
know you know what I mean you might be
able to get in the ballpark but I don't
know if you're gonna get like real exact
because there's just too many factors
there's just too many
slasher Fred said I think one of those
first television children's programs was
the howdy Duty show yeah when did that
first come on 50s that was like yeah I'm
pretty sure that was yeah but no they
had television in the 30s it's just that
they couldn't bring it to Market I think
it was Westinghouse was it
yeah it was something wasn't it yeah I
think it might have been they had it and
they they knew how to do it they had a
couple of prototypes
and then we're gonna take it to Market
but then the war broke out and this is
well we we got to make war material and
there's not going to be a market for
television we'll do it after the war
well in a shitty thing too that happens
a lot is that and I think this might
have happened on either the TV show or
one of the other ones is that somebody
like invents something and it's super
cool and kicks ass but it doesn't catch
on for whatever reason and then like
somebody else with more money and more
like maybe social cachet like finds out
about it it's like oh I'm gonna steal
that idea and so then they steal it and
then they popularize it and then they
[ __ ] over the guy that actually invented
the thing like that happens a lot too
yeah so and there there was one show
like that that really like made me angry
because the guy that actually invented
the [ __ ]
um he kind of like died in penury I
guess and like the guy that just kind of
like stole his idea was uh was like rich
and famous so you know
um
Defcon says my favorite not Freedom Club
forever yeah well yeah we'll get into
that
Victor says hey I made it yeah we're and
we're only just now getting to the
bombing like before we were getting into
uh Ted's kind of background uh you know
in mathematics is college and stuff like
that and his a little bit of his
philosophy and Zach's talking about his
uh beauty standards and their changes
over time I don't think beauty standards
have changed that much
since the very early 1900s or late 1800s
if you look at photographs of people in
the early 1900s
almost everybody you consider them to be
kind of like all as fast as you consider
them to be acceptable they would be
pretty
they're not in style but they're pretty
some of the stuff before that not really
that pretty
um I don't think it changed that much
especially by the night in the 1920s
if you looked at 1920s movie star women
they would fly today they'd be you know
the hair and everything
yeah I mean the thing about it and I
don't even know if that speak just
because nowadays you can kind of wear
whatever and people are just like oh
okay I suppose so but yeah you could
totally wear like some 1920s [ __ ] and
people would be like yeah epic they like
it yeah so I don't think beauty
standards have changed changed they
haven't changed really I don't think
it's just um they do but it's just the
expression minor I guess the expression
of style yeah
but even like big fine and [ __ ] like
they had all that it's just that the
that's not what they were uh
they weren't promoting it the same way
leading ladies were always somebody who
was like in their late teens early 20s
and they were tended to be skinny
but then you had
[ __ ] Mae West May West would be
because it's considered kind of like
[ __ ] thick for a time she was a sex
symbol or later like Jane Mansfield yeah
yeah so they had all that was definitely
a big find yep and uh
they didn't I wouldn't say they weren't
into [ __ ] bootylicious yeah but they
got they were getting close
you know I kind of feel like
bootylicious women back then were more
like uh the magazines that you bought
from underneath the counter yeah like
more than like guys like stars yeah like
[ __ ] you weren't allowed to buy yeah
yeah blue films and [ __ ] right like
yeah stag movies that were [ __ ] that was
traded between guys because porn was an
illegal basically so it was kind of an
underground he had photography clubs is
what they called them but they liked if
you looked at what they were
photographing they liked the same they
like the same kind of women guys like
the same kind of women back then they
like now
and just look at men's porn you know
what I mean and it's just thick they
like thick or you know some girls like
skinny women too but you know it's most
yeah I mean it's kind of all over the
mountains you know guys like novelty you
know whatever stands out that they like
it if it if it looks good and
um but uh no a lot of [ __ ] old
vintage porn
especially by the time the 50s were
rolled around they were into the
bombshell look
big boobs tits and ass
you know Russ Myers looking that's what
they're into
if you looked at the girls he was into
they liked that
the strippers were like that for the
popular ones
Ben says uh one of my favorite
philosophers sorry I just found the
stream and I have to run out to the
dentist in 10 minutes I finally became a
patron though master of dungeons so Ben
is master of dungeons the mystery is
solved thank you very much you were our
actually our first Patron in quite a
long time yeah we don't grow that fast
that's okay slow and steady Winchester
race as they say yep Richard Brown says
Betty Page yeah I love Betty Page yeah
she wasn't skinny but she wasn't big
fine either she was very yeah she was
medium build
but um yeah I was drawn uh inaccurately
a lot if you see yeah the cartoons of
her like don't if you see actual Betty
Page she's not quite as voluptuous as
they no as she's portrayed in the
cartoons but she's still hot though I
always I always liked her I thought she
thought she was really pretty
um let's see Amanda says uh I would wear
some clothing styles from the 80s yeah
some of them were good some of them like
look like look like crap but I don't
have a [ __ ] yes
I could do without those massive [ __ ]
shoulder pads that's for sure and
everything being like triangular yeah
you know what I mean it's like I don't
want to look like a [ __ ] triangle up
here and then a triangle down there with
like the pants like that so you look
like two triangles on top yeah pink
checkered Ward [ __ ] triangle earrings
and [ __ ] no
there was there was [ __ ] 80s and good
80s yeah yeah some [ __ ] about the 80s I
liked but a lot of 80s stuff I didn't I
thought was ugly I actually even thought
it was ugly back then yeah it was tacky
but um you know what I mean tacky and
cheap looking a lot of uh let's see Zach
says Betty Page kind of looks like
people these days she has a very modern
looking face compared to say Marilyn
Monroe yeah I guess she kind of does I
always liked Betty Page because she just
looked like and I think the reason that
she appealed to so many people was she
looked she was beautiful but she was
like regular looking she looked like
approachable I guess when you go through
photographs people look the same
throughout throughout their throughout
[ __ ] centuries you can go back to
Roman stuff Roman statues people still
pretty much look the same what changed
was what was promoted
the looks that Hollywood promoted or the
looks that certain
Styles promoted changed
but if you probably looked at the
population they looked about the same
all the same features yeah I think that
maybe the reason that we're thinking
people look different back then was
mostly because of the clothes and the
hairstyles and stuff because that makes
a huge difference and what they were
going to show you yeah that too who they
would who they would present
that too all I gotta do is you look at
some look at some old movies whenever
they showed uh like African-American
women
they only showed a certain kind of
African-American woman
she was had straight hair for the most
part she looked like a dark-skinned
white woman that's usually what they
showed
um attractive
but that didn't that didn't [ __ ]
represent the average black woman in the
United States at that time yeah that's
not what most of them look like no it's
not most important that was just the
ones that they showed you well it's the
same way with the white women they were
just showing you the the models you know
what I mean the ones that they wanted
you to see the ones that they were
promoting is that this is beautiful this
is what beauty is that's a big show
which like I said it's kind of a bummer
I just like I I kind of feel like the
standards were a lot more rigid back
then yeah because they were just kind of
like well you have to look like this and
they only gave you like a little handful
of options yeah and most people don't
look like that and if you didn't you
were kind of [ __ ] out of luck yeah
exactly you had to be within this or you
weren't but you know what most
developing societies are like that
China's like that right now there's a
certain look that China likes if you're
not in that look you're not a good
looking woman
you're not a good looking training we'll
change one which is funny they had like
a Chinese model [ __ ] who has a very
unique look I think she looked remember
that one we were looking at that they
showed they did a little the little uh
they did a little [ __ ] show about her
China was rejecting her they didn't like
her they thought she was insulting the
Chinese people but she's she's popular
here in the west because she has us just
a unique look
and the Chinese don't like her you know
and uh
but it's like that
developing nations in the United States
is still a developing nature at that
time even though it was like one of the
better countries in the world at that
time in the 20s it was still like a
developing Nation if you went back there
today you'd be like man this place is
backwards that's what you would think
because it was backwards in time you
know
mango says I've got some old movies of
Betty Page and I do too I have a DVD
with a bunch of uh old stuff like a kind
of um what do you call it like a
burlesque type thing was she within Zach
says I think the most gorgeous woman on
Earth at the moment is Lupita nyongo
yeah she is actually really beautiful
um you probably know if you're sorry
um there was a great biopic made about
Betty Page a few years back worth
watching yeah I think that was the one
um I remember the notorious Betty Page
was that yeah that was actually really
good I think I saw it in the theater uh
American Military 100 said Unabomber yes
was waiting eons for 13 o'clock to get
around to this dude okay well we didn't
do it because I thought we'd already
done it but then I was like oh I guess
we did let's get back to the case
actually all right
oh wait Victor says uh Japanese women
are shaving their chin bones for the
Triangular face look
it's ridiculous I mean you know yeah
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do gonna suffer for beauty yes I mean
you don't gotta do but some people want
to I don't know uh all right so we're
only just now like I said we're
recovering like his uh background a
little bit of his philosophy we'll get
into more of that later on because it
kind of
I don't know if it evolved over time but
it kind of people found out more about
it later on
so uh basically Ted's activities
uh started coming to it to the attention
the FBI in 1978 which was when his first
male bomb
was exploded uh so like I said over the
next I believe it was 17 18 years um he
actually mailed or sometimes he hand
delivered uh the [ __ ] too
um you know the bombs and they got like
better better I guess like better at
blowing up like uh you know over time
and like I said eventually it would kill
three people and injure 23 24 people
you're gonna get into what he used yeah
okay we're gonna talk about that
so the first bomb that he sent was a
male bomb and he sent it in Spring of
1978.
to a guy named Buckley Crist at
Northwestern University he was a
materials engineering professor
now the package was actually found in a
parking lot
um at the University of Illinois at
Chicago and the thing about it I don't
know like who the you know sending
address was to but the return address
was hit was him was Buckley Chris so it
was kind of like it was returned to him
and so somebody found it like out in the
parking lot and said oh is this yours
and he's like I didn't send that and so
he thought it was suspicious because it
wasn't his own handwriting like I would
think that was weird too
so he basically like called the campus
police and the security guard and so the
security guard came and the security
guard opened the package and it blew up
damn now um the you know the bomb was
actually this was the first one that he
had made and that he had mailed out and
it wasn't great uh thankfully so it did
blow up and um
the campus policeman whose name is Terry
marker he was injured but he wasn't that
badly hurt he just had like kind of
minimal injuries like his hands were
kind of uh were cut his left hand was
kind of [ __ ] up
so
um the bomb the first one that he made
it was kind of like it was metal from a
home workshop and it was like a piece of
metal pipe like about nine inches long
and one inch in diameter with smokeless
explosive powder in it now the reason
why it didn't
um explode probably as big as Todd
wanted was that the box and the plugs
that sealed the ends of the pipe were
handcrafted wood
now you know I'm not suggesting that
anybody builds it's you know it's the
internet you can find out how to build a
point if you want to but I'm just saying
I'm not telling anybody to build pipe
bomb ever it's most people now but if
you but pipe bombs usually they have
like metal caps on the end because you
want constrained you know pressure
but because the wood is on the ends like
it didn't contain the [ __ ] so it didn't
blow up as big as uh as it should have
um so basically what happened I think
that the trigger device that he used to
was just like he used a nail with like a
rubber band like keeping it kind of
tensioned and then
um the nail was supposed to kind of go
off and like hit some match heads he had
like six match heads in there yeah but
the nail only hit like three of them so
it didn't really get you know what I
mean and like I said to the Caps were
wood so it just kind of like it's with a
little bit more porous than metal so it
didn't work out as good
okay like I said thankfully so it only
hurt the guy's hand he wasn't hurt that
bad
um so that's it so later on Ted would
figure out
unfortunately
um that he was that he would use uh like
batteries and a heat filament wire that
would explode the [ __ ] yeah he got the
battery out of the damn flexible
instamatic camera film
you know when you have a
uh
of the old Polaroid cameras and had the
film that came out the bottom of that
thing is a battery so he would
cut that out and that's where the
battery was the filament that he got was
from the flash Cube
The Flash cube out of the out of a
Polaroid camera yeah that's what he was
doing
Ben said people don't realize how common
bombings and letter bombings were in the
70s yeah there was like a lot of like
[ __ ] uh uh bomb foot on planes and
like mail bombings and [ __ ] like that I
mean the 70s was
a rough time it was a rough time late
60s and 70s there was a lot of better
bombers don't want to get caught
yeah that's their main thing they don't
want to get caught that's why they do
that
mass Shooters and [ __ ] like that they
don't care if they get caught it's a
[ __ ] suicide attack yeah it's a
completely different technological
profile right the whole thing the whole
reason why there's [ __ ] bombs and
letter bombs and male bombs and [ __ ]
like that Bob's set is because the dudes
a [ __ ] does not want to get caught
he's scared of getting caught which is
kind of funny but that's his primary
[ __ ] mentality don't catch me
you know you know who Ted Kaczynski
reminds me of a little bit
um the whoever it was that did the uh
Tylenol poisonings yeah you remember
that we did a show about that like a
while back I kind of feel like I don't
think they ever caught that person but
um I mean they caught a person that said
they were him but they that wasn't him I
don't think it was him no they but the
guy that said it was him was just doing
it like to get money like for blackmail
yeah and they so they got him for that
but they didn't think he did that
certain kind of offender doesn't want to
get caught
scared
well and I kind of feel like I I don't
know like a dish just occurred to me but
I think that the similarities are that
usually you get somebody like Ted
Kaczynski or like the person that did
the Tylenol poisonings I kind of feel
like it's a person that
feels
Superior in some ways like and they
maybe get off on
having this kind of god-like power where
they can just choose somebody at random
and it's like I can just send you a bomb
through the mail or I can just like put
some poison in your Tylenol and you'll
just pick it up off the shelf I think
they get off on that idea of
being in that position like being in a
superior position and just being able to
like off somebody randomly and like you
can't do anything about it like I kind
so I kind of feel like it's the same
kind of psychology and like I said I'm
as far as I know we did a show about the
Tylenol poisonings not too long ago but
as far as I know they haven't caught
that person that did that that was in
Chicago area too weirdly
um but yeah
so uh so later on he sent some bombs to
um some officials for different airlines
and then
um yeah this is one that actually when
the FBI got involved actually in 1979
not 19 1978 like I said before but
um 1979 uh he actually got a bomb placed
in the cargo hold of American Airlines
flight 444 which was flying from Chicago
to Washington DC now the bomb got in
there it was in the cargo hold
thankfully again it didn't go off to its
full capacity
um it started smoking
uh at which point the pilot was alerted
to the smoke and the cargo hold and did
an emergency landing so thankfully
nobody was hurt uh they did have like
they did have to treat some uh
passengers for smoke inhalation but that
was like the worst of it uh basically it
had like the timing um the timing
mechanism on it was not working
correctly and uh thankfully like I said
because if it had been working correctly
um it would have blown the entire plane
up
so I'm not sure how many passengers were
on the plane but
too many so yeah thankfully nobody was
hurt in that instance but he was
planning on blowing up a plane which
not [ __ ] cool Ted seriously uh so
obviously bombing an airliner is uh not
a good thing that's a federal crime uh
so the FBI got into it and that was when
they started calling him uni bomb like I
said u n a b-o-m like acronym University
and Airline bomber
uh they also came in with like uh you
the U.S postal inspectors they also
became involved as well uh they had been
the ones that have been working it prior
to this so they were working together
with the FBI actually the postal
inspectors had been calling him the
junkyard bomber because
um the stuff that he used to make the
bombs very specifically he would use
stuff that you could just get anywhere
like you know because he didn't want to
get caught you don't want anything
that's like gonna stick out or like you
know it's just stuff that you can find
at hardware stores and [ __ ] like that
so 1979 uh they put together a fbi-led
task force um you had the U.S postal
inspection service like I said you had
the ATF and they all got together and
started like investigating the case and
eventually
um it would be like 150 people were
working on this like at one time like I
said because it went on for a really
long time they didn't catch this guy for
like 17 years and they started doing
like forensic examination on all the
parts of the bombs uh they started kind
of like everybody that had been targeted
including everybody that had been on the
plane and all the people that got the
mail bombs so far
um they looked into their background is
there any possible like why is this
person targeted is there some possible
so they were like combing through every
single detail looking for a way to like
catch this [ __ ] but they said it
was like really really hard because like
I said the stuff that he was making the
bombs out of was just regular [ __ ] it
was just stuff that you could get
anywhere like in any hardware store in
America and nothing about it was
distinctive you know what I mean so that
was uh really stymying their
investigation
um and as I mentioned the the victims
which they looked into their past and
everything but they said that the
victims were not necessarily chosen for
any specific reason they were just kind
of the guy would just like I said Ted
would just go to the library and he'd be
like well I'm maybe pissed off at this
industry like a you know an airline or
something like that and then he would
just go through like uh you know list at
the library and like pick a name
and he would just like send [ __ ] there
you know what I mean so he wasn't
picking people specifically really he
was just kind of like picking people
sort of at random that sort of kind of
had something to do with something he
was mad at so
which again periphery you guys right
it's just you know people that are like
didn't know him and he didn't Target
anybody he knew or that he had once
associated with now he did like send
some bombs later to some people at like
Berkeley and stuff like that but you
know in a couple ones that he sent to
people that I don't know if he like knew
them or if it was like because he did
say later that some of this stuff was
Revenge so maybe he did know some people
and they pissed him off I don't know but
like generally most of the people he
sent him to I don't think he knew them
personally he just kind of picked him
out of a book so
uh so 1980
uh you got the FBI chief agent John
Douglas and they put together a
psychological profile of the bomber and
like I said this many years before they
caught him
and this is funny because they actually
kind of nailed it at first they said uh
this is a man with above average
intelligence with connections to
Academia check
uh they also said uh that he would have
be a neo-luddite big check
uh who had an academic degree in the
hard Sciences again hard another check
um but they decided in 1983 that
um no that's probably not right like
other FBI analysts came in and said no
we don't think that's correct we think
that this guy is maybe a blue-collar guy
who worked for the Airlines and the
airlines were pissing him off
specifically like he was a mechanic or
something but I was like no you should
have gone with the first thing you were
exactly right but they didn't know they
didn't know back then I mean it could
have been because like I said sometimes
like some of these bombing campaigns
like sometimes it is dudes that you know
worked for a company and they had a
specific like grudge against this
company because the company [ __ ] them
over somehow and it's just like oh I'm
gonna bomb people at this company but
then I'm gonna like bomb other random
people too so it's like to throw the you
know throw suspicion off me so I have
heard of that happening so it's not
crazy like to think that but it's just
funny how on the nose they were at first
but then like later they came in and
said no don't think that's right I'm
like no that was right but you know
hindsight's 20 20. what are you gonna do
uh so basically the so they set up a
hotline
um and they're and they offered like a
million dollar reward like for anyone
that could come up with any information
that would lead to his capture right
now uh so prior to this like I said
you'd had
mail bombs that had just given like
minor injuries because most of the time
they either they blew up and you know no
one was around or they blew up and it
just like hurt someone's hand or
something like that no one was horribly
seriously injured
um but the first Serious injury happened
in 1985 uh there was a guy named John
Hauser he was actually a graduate
student
um and he was also in the Air Force he
was a captain uh he was mailed a bomb
and he um actually it blew up and he
lost four of his fingers and uh the
vision in one eye
so this was a bomb uh that was
handcrafted with wooden parts so and I
don't know why he targeted that person
specifically so I don't I don't know why
like I said he's just picking random
people
now the first person that was killed by
one of Ted kaczynski's bombs was a man
named Hugh scrutin and he owned a
computer store in California he was 38
years old
this was also in 1985 and he was
actually killed the bomb was like a nail
and Splinter loaded bomb and it was just
put like in a package in the parking lot
of his store
and you know he just found in the
parking lot and he did I don't think he
opened it I think he was just picking it
up to move it and it blew up uh and it
killed him
there was another attack against another
computer store owner like and that
happened in Salt Lake City Utah and that
was in February of 1987. now this bomb
he actually like disguised it as like a
piece of lumber and left it out in the
parking lot
and either the owner or a guy that
worked at the computer store his name
was Gary Wright he's tried to move it
out of the parking lot and exploded now
he wasn't killed but it severed a bunch
of nerves in his left arm and
um put a bunch it like his body was like
full of shrapnel they said it was like
200 pieces of shrapnel like when going
into his body
now for about six years
um there weren't any more attacks not
really sure what was going on in Ted's
life at that point but there was a
six-year hiatus
so Ted comes out of retirement I guess
and Strikes Again in 1993.
and he mails a bomb to a guy named David
gallerter galanter I think is how you
pronounce his last name I apologize if
that's not right uh he was a computer
science professor at Yale which you know
like I said again Yale he didn't go
there but whatever
um now uh David gallerter was hurt but I
mean he was hurt bad but he did actually
like eventually recover so he didn't die
um the same weekend Ted mailed another
bomb to uh the house of a geneticist
named Charles Epstein from the
University of California San Francisco
he opened the package and it blew off
several of his fingers
um and after that Ted Kaczynski this
might have been one of the few times
that he did this he actually then called
the brother of David uh galancha the
first guy that he had sent the bomb to
and the guy's brother was like a
behavioral geneticist and he called him
and said you're next but as far as I
know I don't know if he ever sent him a
bomb but he did send him like a bunch of
threatening letters like a couple of
years after that but I don't think he
ever sent him a bomb
now at this point and like I said he's
been doing this for a while but it was
the 1990s before he started like writing
to the media and like taking credit for
the [ __ ] so he writes to the New York
Times and he says that his group which
he calls the FC or the freedom Club was
responsible for all of these attacks
or there's a guy named Thomas Mosser now
he was an executive at a company called
Burston marsteller and he was sent a
mail bomb that was sent to him at his
house in North Caldwell New Jersey and
it went off and he was killed
um and also after this because again
Kaczynski sent another letter to the New
York Times and said that the FC his
little club or whatever that he made up
quote blew up Thomas Mosser because
burst and Marcel or the company helped
Exxon clean up its Public Image after
the Exxon Valdez incident
and be also because quote its business
is the development of techniques for
manipulating people's attitudes that's
what he said like in the letter that he
sent probably and that and that was why
he blew the guy up okay
1995
um he killed his third victim a guy
named Gilbert Murray who is actually
president of a Timber industry lobbying
group the California Forestry
Association
um and this was actually I don't know if
it was intended for him because the male
bomb that killed him was actually
addressed to the previous president of
the thing so I guess he was just like
whoever the president is he was going to
blow him up or you know but the previous
president have retired so the next guy
got the bomb and he got killed
unfortunately
so in all we have 16 bombs and this
ended up injuring 23 people and killing
three people
and these were the ones that were all
attributed to Ted Kaczynski now the
devices as we said
um you know started out very very
primitive with like the nail and the
match heads and everything like that but
eventually like evolved into being more
sophisticated
um all of them though except for the
first few that he did that he was still
apparently experimenting with all of
them had the initials FC somewhere like
inside the bombs he would put like a
piece in there that had the inscription
FC on it like I said for Freedom Club so
he put that in there as like a signature
um interestingly they said that there
was some latent fingerprints on some of
the devices that didn't match the
fingerprints that were found on some of
kaczynski's letters which led some
people to speculate that he wasn't
working alone although everyone's pretty
sure that probably he was but I'm not
real sure like
I mean that's the thing though somebody
there could have been like lots of other
explanations for that like why there
were other fingerprints on there who
knows maybe it could have been the
person at the hardware store I don't
know
um so another thing that Ted did a lot
was he would plant like false clues in
all the bombs
so he like like I said he would always
put like a little metal plate that had
FC on it like stamped on it hidden
somewhere usually in the pipe or the cap
or whatever
um and one kind of little fake clue that
he left in one bomb that didn't detonate
he put a little note in there that said
Woo it works I told you it would and
then he put like the initials RV after
it like it was a note like to somebody
or something like that he's like trying
to throw people off you know what I mean
um he also would use like really
distinctive stamps like to send this
stuff like to throw people off stuff
like that
um they said one of his bombs was sent
inside a copy of a novel called Ice
brothers by Sloane Wilson so but he was
always like just picking random [ __ ]
like that because he thought it would
send people send the FBI like down the
wrong trail
uh the FBI also noticed that Ted had a
recurring theme of like nature trees and
wood in his crimes like I said earlier
like um in his inside his bombs he would
often put like bark and like little
pieces of tree branches and [ __ ] like
that
um and some of the people that he
targeted that he didn't really know
personally had wood or something like
that in their names like one of the guys
that he sent it was to his name Percy
wood one was named uh Leroy wood bearson
and Thomas Mosser you know what I mean
so he picked like people with names like
that which like I said was
kind of more him just targeting that
like to send a message rather than
that person like specifically pissing
him off you know what I mean weird yeah
well like I said he was just getting
lunar and lunier out there I kind of
feel like
um so yeah so 1995 uh Ted mails a whole
bunch of letters uh including some to
people that he had sent bombs to
previously and others to several you
know newspapers and other major media
outlets and he is basically like
outlining his goals like what he's
hoping to achieve
and demanding that his essay let his
industrial society and its future that's
what it's called that's the that's the
real name of the Unabomber Manifesto
It's actually called industrial society
it's future uh which was 50 odd pages
and 35 000 words he actually demanded
that that had to be printed verbatim in
a major newspaper or he was going to
bomb more people
so uh so this Unabomber Manifesto which
a lot of people have read you can find
it very easily online you can even
listen to the audiobook if you if that's
your bag
um pretty much calling for a worldwide
Revolution against the effects of modern
society's industrial technological
system
so he sends this to a bunch of media
outlets and as is usual in these kind of
cases they have the same kind of thing
with the Zodiac like this kind of [ __ ]
they're like should we print it because
it's like it seems like because you
don't want to like do what a terrorist
asks you to do
but on the other hand it's like you
don't want people's blood on your hands
if you don't publish it and it actually
goes through with the threat and blows
some innocent people up you know what
I'm saying
so basically they were like okay well
we're gonna print it because we don't
want anybody to get blown up and they're
like and plus if we print it because
it's so long and it's so detailed and
the way that it's written is so specific
we're kind of hoping that someone will
read it and recognize who this
[ __ ] is like by the way that
it's written which as it turned out
that's what happened so it's probably a
good thing that they published it
so the New York Times Did publish it and
the Washington Post also published the
whole thing like they published it like
in a little pamphlet that came with the
paper
uh also Bob gucciano
uh he volunteered to publish it but Ted
Kaczynski didn't want Penthouse to
publish it because uh he thought it
wasn't respectable okay
so all right
uh he said I think that Ted said that if
Penthouse published it that he would um
that he would quote reserve the right to
plant one and only one bomb intended to
kill after our manuscript has been
published so he was like doing a
compromise well if only Penthouse will
publish I'll only blow up one person
right
instead of the I'm like okay this dudes
are not so basically I mean
okay
now okay so he had typed this whole
[ __ ] thing on a typewriter
uh that didn't have any italics or
anything like that it was like an old
school typewriter so like when he wanted
to emphasize something it would be like
in all caps and everything like that now
he never he always refers to himself as
FC Freedom club or we
um although they don't think that he had
any you know they think that he acted
alone
um basically it's just kind of like this
is actually one of the first cases and I
think there's a documentary about this
on Netflix and I still need to watch it
because it's probably like really
interesting but this is one of the first
cases where linguistic forensics was
like a big factor in catching the guy
because like I said his style of writing
was so specific and the way that he used
certain phrases and [ __ ] like that
because they had a lot of like
Linguistics experts come in and like
analyze and that was one of the things
that like helped him catch him
so basically what uh the manifesto
starts with is Ted says the Industrial
Revolution and its consequences have
been a disaster for the human race
uh basically talking about uh coming in
and like [ __ ] on uh leftists
scientists
um living within an industrial
technological system uh which causes
horrible psychological consequences uh
taking away people's autonomy and
freedom
um diminishing their rapport with nature
forcing them to behave in ways that are
increasingly remote from the natural
pattern of human behavior
um so he's school so he's basically yeah
he was against anything that yeah was at
yeah I mean I kind of agreed with him on
that he wanted like a revolution against
technology he said he said boys should
not be in a school anywhere near a
school during puberty
that's probably true
as soon as they start going through that
they need to be out [ __ ] doing
you know doing sports and [ __ ] doing
physical stuff and then once it's over
you can bring him back he said when
they're in their late teens you can
bring them back and continue their
education I think it might be something
too that once they can like sit down
once you can sit down and think yeah
other than like running around like
running around like a [ __ ] walking
hard on
[Laughter]
yeah Michael strandeki said some FBI Pro
profilers took credit for catching him
with a linguistic profile [ __ ] his
brother read the manifesto and found
similar language in his letters yeah I
brought that up earlier and I'm going to
like talk about that later yeah it was
actually kind of like I think like
Heather recognized well I think his
sister-in-law yeah recognized it first
and went to the brother and said hey
this sounds like Ted even though she'd
never met him but she'd read like some
of his letters and I think the brother
like David is the brother's name and um
he was like yeah I don't wanna I don't
want that to be Ted but he went in in
the garage or whatever and like found
some of Ted's old letters then he was
starting to read it and he was like oh
[ __ ] maybe it is him you know what I
mean so I think yeah that's what
happened
um let's see so uh so basically I'm just
like reading a couple little things like
out of the thing I'm not you know you
can go read the whole thing if you want
to but he's basically saying uh he calls
people over socialized he says the moral
code of our society is so demanding that
no one can think feel and act in a
completely moral way some people are so
highly socialized that the attempt to
think feel and act morally imposes a
severe burden on them in order to avoid
feelings of guilt they continually have
to deceive themselves about their own
motives and find moral explanations for
feelings and actions that in reality
have a non-moral origin we use the term
over socialized to describe such people
the thing about it though I kind of got
like reading through some of his stuff
the impression that I got of Ted
Kaczynski was that he's one of those
people that
takes his own
personality and projects it outward onto
other people where maybe it doesn't
apply I mean some of the stuff that he's
saying I'm like yeah you feel like that
but not everybody feels like that but
he's generalizing like everyone else
feels the same way that he feels even
though he's obviously one way more
intelligent than most people and a lot
more socially awkward and introverted
than the average person so I think he's
coming at it from that
more unusual standpoint
but he's generalizing in that to
everybody where I think it doesn't apply
to the same degree as it might apply to
him you know what I mean do you see what
I'm saying yeah you see what I'm saying
yep and I don't know if that's true but
I I just kind of got that impression
because I was like reading some of the
[ __ ] and like I said some of the [ __ ]
that he says there's nothing weird about
or nothing wrong with some of the [ __ ]
he's probably like right about and some
of the stuff I was like yeah he's got a
point there and [ __ ] like that but some
of the stuff he's saying I'm like that's
just you man he's projecting that's just
you and it's like and you're projecting
that onto the rest of us like you know
what I mean it's like technology doesn't
make me particularly unhappy or anything
like I know it does make some people
unhappy because you know some people do
say that but it doesn't bother me at all
it's like I don't I don't think that I
would wanna
go back and I don't think that's the
[ __ ] solution he's one of those dudes
that Captain Kirk was trying to get to
Eden man remember that [ __ ] uh Star
Trek episode where they're [ __ ]
trying to get to Eden yeah that's right
[ __ ] poisonous yeah
that's right yeah he's one of those like
I said there's absolutely nothing wrong
with just you like if you're like hey
you know I'm not real into this whole
technology I don't like social media I
don't want a cell phone I just want to
go live in the forest and have a simple
life and fish and [ __ ] like that I just
want to go do that go do that you're not
hurting anybody you're not hurting a
single soul you just go and you live
your best life
but
if you want to do that don't make
everybody else do that too because not
everybody wants to do it I don't want to
do that you know what I mean I'm not
[ __ ] on if you do want to do that
but I'm just saying don't don't take
something that you want to do and
pretend like everybody else wants to do
the same [ __ ] you want to do because
they don't I certainly don't I don't
want all my technology taken away you
can pry my air conditioning for my cold
dead fingers I'm just saying right now
among other things yeah and the thing
about it is like well [ __ ] man it's like
I make my whole living practically like
on the Internet it's like I would be
hosed if I don't like [ __ ] go back so
I mean I could do it but it would take
it would be like a really long uh
process of
adaptation because I've kind of
built this whole thing around like
technology and everything like that and
it's like if I didn't have that I'd be
in big trouble and honestly and I've
said a lot of times before I'm
you know I'm real introverted I don't
really like all that much like doing
face-to-face stuff on a big uh you know
scale or anything like that I don't mind
it like in small doses but I don't
really like
having to interact with people face to
face like on its very it uh it's very
exhausting for me so I mean the Advent
of I mean then when the 90s came along
and the Advent of like email it's like
oh my God I can send people I don't have
to talk to people on the phone anymore
oh my God that's [ __ ] awesome and
it's like the fact that I can you know
write books and like I can do all the
[ __ ] myself and I don't have to see
anybody I don't know how to type them
but just put shut up that's amazing I
don't I don't want that taken away so
like I said I'm almost like I get
I get Ted kaczynski's like being
introverted and all that kind of stuff
because I have that too but it's like I
went in the opposite direction I think
technology is like really good for
people like that it like facilitates uh
relationships and stuff like that when
maybe like I said you don't want to get
out and like talk to people face to face
because it's exhausting or whatever it's
like you know it's really much easier
nowadays you couldn't pursue the
internet that's what I'm saying about
this so I'm kind of Wonder like what
he's feeling about it now because like I
said he's still alive he's in a super
max but in Colorado but I don't really
know
you know I don't know what the terms are
like I don't know how uh how that works
like what access he would have to a
particular level of technology to let
prisoners go on the internet I would
imagine probably not no I mean he writes
letters and stuff yeah you would think
that I mean that didn't have computer no
I mean I feel like even if they did it
would be very off-brand for him to go
and build a website yeah yeah
like on Wix or something doesn't have
internet how [ __ ] funny would that be
though like some of them are allowed
phones but
I don't know I don't think he has
internet
I just I just thought that would be
really amusing honestly it's probably
like
some people though that
um
that are followers of Ted because
because he does have admirers like
they've read his uh Manifesto and are
like yeah bro you're right on but I'm
like yeah but you're on the internet
though I mean Ted would not have
advocated like you being on the internet
even talking about Ted you know what I'm
saying that was kind of against his
whole deal
but yeah so
I don't know it's just like a funny kind
of like Paradox I guess
uh so uh so yeah there was just some
like other stuff yeah this is what he
was saying before about
um surrogate activities so he's saying
that because I guess because we live in
a technological Society where a lot of
stuff is kind of like taken care of or
was like easier or whatever
um that now people are doing what he
called surrogate activities
um which were activities directed toward
an artificial goal that people set up
for themselves merely in order to have
some goal to work toward or uh let us
say merely for the sake of fulfillment
that they get from pursuing the goal
but see I'm like well
what's wrong with that though I don't
really get like what I just think he's
just a really angry person and he thinks
everyone else is like an angry person
too but I don't know so
um
yeah and so another thing that he said
too was that uh one of these surrogate
activities was scientific research and
he's like so and this is a quote science
Marches On blindly without regard to the
real welfare of the human race or to any
other standard obedient obedient only to
the psychological needs of the
scientists and the government officials
and Corporation Executives who provide
the funds for research which like I said
to a degree that's probably true but I
don't think that's true like across the
board you know what I'm saying
so yeah uh so I'm just wait like
skipping through some [ __ ] that he wrote
like yeah he was against like the Sylvan
Learning Centers uh he just thought he
just was one of those [ __ ] that
thought like everything was
indoctrination but like I said I'm not
really sure
what
what is what do they want though like
what's the alternative like I said if
you want to check out of that then you
can there's nothing stopping you from
doing that but it's like why do you
think everyone else should I thought it
was going to end the world
right and enslaved people and stuff
though you know yeah he you know it
wasn't just for him he thought it was
ending the world
from what I remember
it's a long time ago that I read it yeah
but uh you know that it was going to be
kind of like Global enslavement and
[ __ ] uh then eventually like a
collapse
which yeah and like so people are still
saying that nowadays but I don't know
I don't know
so let me see but yeah like I said
that's um kind of like
that's the thing a lot of people like
some philosophers and things like that
um you'll get a lot of them that are
like yeah he had some good ideas which
like I said he did
um you know some of the [ __ ] in there
was you know he had a point and
everything like that but obviously you
have to come out and be like well
obviously like bombing innocent people
is really not the best go way to go
about like getting your beliefs out
there done so I don't really know what
the problem is there uh so before the
manifesto was published
uh Ted kaczynski's Brother David uh as I
mentioned before his wife Linda now the
thing about it was that Ted and David
had been estranged for quite a while I
think it had been like a decade at this
point I'm not sure I think the reason
and I'm not sure exactly what the reason
was but I heard that the reason was that
for whatever reason Ted didn't like or
didn't want his brother to get married
to Linda who eventually became his wife
I don't know if he didn't like her or he
he just didn't like the idea or whatever
but that's what I heard was kind of like
the thing that caused the big rift he
said well we didn't
um communicate a lot prior to that now
the thing about it was that David was
also kind of a guy that's like oh I like
to kind of live off the grid he had some
land I think some like in Texas or
something and he had a cabin out there
too but he's like I went out there to
just like can I unwind and like do some
self-reflection and stuff like that
whereas like Ted went out there to kind
of like [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm just
gonna get away from everybody because
because of that like it seemed like he
was coming at it Ted was coming at it
more from a place of like anger whereas
David was coming at it more of a place
of like peace you know what I mean like
so it was kind of like two and David
said he thought that that was very
strange because
he's like Ted was so
anti-technology and anti-science he's
like even though that was kind of like
how his mind worked it's like his mind
worked very in a very binary fashion so
he always thought it was very ironic
that
um that Ted was so anti-technology like
in the way that he was but so but so
yeah so David said that he had also like
spent a lot of time like kind of Off the
Grid like on his own land like in Texas
or whatever but they had been estranged
possibly allegedly because Ted for
whatever reason didn't like him getting
married to Linda I don't know if it was
because he didn't like her or whatever
so they hadn't really talked in a while
but when the manifesto was published
um his wife Linda kind of read it and
she was like that sounds like Ted as I
said she'd never met him in person but
she had read some of his letters and
stuff and she thought that the the turns
of phrase that he used like just the
stuff that he said like sounded like him
now at first Ted was kind of like I
don't know if it is but he went and took
out some old letters and started reading
them and the more he read he was like
yeah I think it actually might be now
before he went to the FBI
he apparently went to their mother and
said um you know hey I'm thinking about
I think Ted is the human bomber and I'm
thinking about turning him in what do
you think I should do uh the mom
obviously didn't want to believe it and
she's like but after they kind of like
talked about it she was like yeah maybe
you should like yeah because David
clearly like loved his brother very much
and he just thought that he was
protecting his brother and protecting
other innocent people by turning him in
which he absolutely was so that was the
right thing to do
but um but also before he went to the
FBI he also like he got a lawyer he got
all this other stuff and he basically
went to the FBI and he said look
I'm gonna tell like I'm pretty sure this
is my brother and he gave over like all
the letters and everything but he's like
please please please
do not tell Ted that it was me don't
tell anybody that it was me that turned
him in because he was afraid that Ted
would maybe like lash out not
necessarily even against him but but
maybe would like lash out against like
some innocent people are like that
because he would get mad because he
would feel betrayed so he's like I
really don't want him to know that it
was me
that turned him in I don't want anybody
to know
unfortunately though
um
it leaked
so um I will say though that um because
remember how I said there was a one
million dollar reward yeah uh David
actually did get that but because he's a
cool guy he actually donated the money
uh to
um the victims so uh so I thought that
was a cool thing that he did
but basically so so yeah
so the [ __ ] leaked out like that it was
him that had done it
now at first
um and this is like I don't know why
this may be sad this whole thing just
made me sad
they told Ted at first when they first
told him uh it was your brother David
that turned you in basically
and Ted said my brother would never
that's impossible he loves me he would
never do that
and then like when they were like no it
really was him like Ted just would not
talk to his brother anymore and as far
as I know still hasn't although David
keeps writing to him like he sends him a
letter like every single month but he's
like Ted will not write him back because
he feels betrayed but I was like but
you know the fact that he loved you
that's why he turned you in like maybe
one day he'll understand that but I
doubt it so yeah he was at War man
that's what I'm saying well but the
thing about it is like he seems like the
kind of guy that and it's really sad I
mean it didn't have to go this way like
I said he he honestly had so much he
could have given the world
um but he went this way and
it really doesn't help anybody and it's
just like a [ __ ] tragedy man it's
just like a really really sad story and
it's it's sad for his family it's sad
for his victims and their families and
it's just it could have gone a different
way and it just didn't and it was just I
don't know this this really like made me
sad this whole [ __ ] story
but um but yeah so like I said I kind of
feel like
um David too was thinking that maybe you
know before they caught him that there
was going to be like a Waco kind of
situation or some [ __ ] like that because
he wasn't sure like he hadn't talked to
his brother in a long time but he's like
the [ __ ] that he's writing is like
sounds kind of out there like some
[ __ ] you know like that kind of [ __ ]
so he didn't really know what was gonna
happen he didn't know what his State of
Mind was and honestly when the FBI went
there and got him I mean when they
pulled him out that house it was all
over the news right and he looked like a
crazy person you know his hair was all
crazy and [ __ ] [ __ ] like that so he
probably wasn't too far off he didn't
know what his State of Mind was going to
be like at the time
so I mean that's the thing
uh I kind of lost my place at this thing
all right what are we reading oh okay
yeah
Michael says I agree with most of it he
was saying that because people in power
would have access to the same technology
that it wasn't good they would use it
for bad instead of good
yeah that's the thing like he was right
about that like like I said I'm not
saying that he wasn't he I don't think
he was crazy I mean I think that he was
on to some [ __ ] but
I just think that he went like too far
you know what I mean he went like too
far off the deep end and obviously like
took some uh uh some very very
unfortunate
very unfortunate methods of like getting
his getting his message across Senor
stick said was he crazy or a native
Xanax that's I mean he yeah he needed to
like chill out like I said he
he needed to like not be inside his own
head all the time I think that was one
of his main problems too because he just
pre probably just got in this like
endless feedback loop where he was just
kept where stuff kept like building up
in his mind you know what I mean
so he got arrested in April of 1996. I
remember this happening it was all over
the news uh so they arrest pulled him
out of his cabin in Lincoln Montana and
he was Wikipedia said found in an
unkempt State yeah uh he looked a little
unkempt uh they pulled him out yeah he
looked like
a nut I mean
his hair was all wild like his pants he
had his pants had big [ __ ] holes in
him there oh it's all crusty and
everything like that
so they go through his cabin
because you know they're like they're
pretty sure it's him because you know
they've done the linguistic analysis and
all that kind of stuff like 60 percent
sure we're pretty sure this is him and
the linguistic analysis and everything
like that was enough for them to get the
search warrant but they still weren't
entirely sure that this was their guy
but then when they get into the cabin uh
they became 100 sure that this was the
guy because they found uh a whole bunch
of bomb components they found 40
000 handwritten Pages uh that included a
bunch of like bomb making experiments uh
and descriptions of the crimes that the
Unabomber had already committed uh oh
and also they found one live bomb that
he was getting ready to mail so you know
found a typewriter too I think a little
yeah so you know a little incriminating
a little incriminating
um uh and they found the yeah they've
also found the original typed manuscript
of the manifesto
so uh yes they're like oh well okay that
was easy
this is the guy clearly so at this point
I think this had been I don't know about
uh now it's probably like been surpassed
at this point but I think this was like
the most expensive investigation that
the FBI had undertaken up to this point
um so yeah I mean there were some people
that thought that Manifesto had been
written by a different person and blah
blah but I doubt it like I said his is
if it's even his own sister-in-law and
brother like recognized it then it
probably was that dude
so yeah so like I said uh David even
though they said that he would be
anonymous when he turned his brother in
uh somebody they don't know who uh
leaked it to CBS News
and it was all over the place so the FBI
were still doing like still uh doing the
search warrant like when it leaked so
they had to like hurry up and finish the
[ __ ] because like I said they didn't
want like [ __ ] to go sideways like if he
found out that his brother turned him in
blah blah
now uh as I mentioned earlier after he
was arrested uh they thought they
investigated him a little bit for the
Zodiac crimes but they quickly
determined that um he was not in the
area he was actually in Illinois like
during some of the crimes so it couldn't
have been him
uh basically what they wanted to do at
first his lawyers advised Ted Kaczynski
to enter an insanity defense
but Ted Kaczynski did not want to do he
was adamant that he did not want anyone
to see him as insane because he thought
I guess that it would undercut his
message if everyone just thought he was
a crazy person
now they gave him a court-appointed
psychiatrist and this psychiatrist
diagnosed him as having paranoid
schizophrenia which
yeah probably I mean that seems that
seems uh pretty pretty accurate
but uh said that he was competent to
stay on trial
now basically uh there were some other
ones though there were a couple of other
psychiatrists who came up with a book
later on that said
um they didn't think that he had
paranoid schizophrenia that that would
that had been a what they called a
political diagnosis but I'm not sure I
mean just like from the writings of his
that I read that sounds like paranoid
schizophrenia to me I'm not a
psychiatrist but that sounds in line
with other stuff but you know that was
written by people that with that
disorder
so uh so it's grand jury indicted Ted
Kaczynski in April 1996 10 counts of
illegally transporting mailing and using
bombs uh and was also charged with three
murders obviously for the three victims
that he killed
January 7 1998 Ted attempted to hang
himself in his cell with his underwear
uh to avoid having to submit to a
psychiatric evaluation but they gave him
another one anyway
so uh basically the here's the thing
that I brought up earlier that a long
time ago uh that you said you didn't
know about so this was apparently in the
psychiatrist's report like after the
after his suicide attempt
so I guess she talked to him about his
upbringing and his past and his teenage
years and everything like that
he said that when he was at Harvard and
keep in mind that he was very young he
started going to Harvard when he was 16.
so he was much younger than you know
most of the Harvard students were and he
had some problems because of that
um he called what he was going through
he said he went through depression and
that he called a acute sexual starvation
the kid's sexual service that's what he
I know all about it
yeah yeah a cute sexual star hell yeah
yeah
yeah
you don't have a cute sexual starvation
I'm like Jenny she's like nah [ __ ]
I'm busy
okay yeah
oh my God poor you yeah pecker in the
hand and everything
it's Tom
cute sexual starvation it's cute man
it's a cute sexual starvation yeah
you're sitting on top of the bed taking
a hand
starving looking cute starving starving
[ __ ] for sex yeah looking cute oh my
God it's a cute sexual stuff
yeah it's adorable yeah
so uh so basically This was
um this whole episode in his life
apparently this is where I guess from
the psychiatrist report it says this
culminated in several weeks of intense
and persistent sexual excitement
involving fantasies of being a female
during that time period he became
convinced that he should underco undergo
sex change surgery like I said what I
heard from what I read like on a
different Source was that
he basically went like an in-cell route
where he was like well I'm never gonna
touch a woman unless I become a woman it
was kind of like that I'm paraphrasing
but that's kind of like what they said
so he actually allegedly uh scheduled an
appointment with the campus psychiatrist
to kind of get the ball rolling on the
whole because like I said it's a huge
long process so he was gonna do that uh
but he would and he even went into the
appointment and like was in the waiting
room and everything but apparently like
he chickened out
and uh so before he left he just said oh
well I didn't really want to be a woman
I was just like afraid I was going to
get drafted and so I was like okay now
you're in University okay Klinger yeah
you know what I mean
he was at University they're not going
to draft him
that's what I mean it's like well that
was the excuse that he used because just
because he chickened out of like but he
yeah he went through like a really weird
like several week period where you want
his pecker cut off I can understand it
well he's yeah he thought that he wanted
to be a woman which like I said
you know I I hate to like you know I
don't want to make fun of the dude it's
like yeah I know he killed a bunch of
innocent people and that's [ __ ] up
okay but I mean he wasn't right
and it's it's kind of sad because
like I said he was so smart he was like
he was such an intellectual giant he
really could have done a lot of great
things but he just
he couldn't hack it I mean he just
really couldn't
and a lot of [ __ ] was like a lot of bad
[ __ ] was done to him too like that
experiment although I mean to be fair he
did volunteer for that but he didn't
volunteer for it knowing what it was
going to entail exactly because they
didn't really tell him you know what I
mean he just volunteered because he
thought it was like a psychological
study he was going to make some extra
money but it ended up being like a three
year long psychological torture
essentially like every now and then so
and like I said I'm not saying that that
was the main thing but I'm sure it
didn't help you know what I'm saying and
because he was already the way he was
I'm sure that that just exacerbated that
whole situation
so um so yeah so apparently this is from
Ted's Diaries like after he walked out
of this appointment he said as I walked
away from the building afterwards I felt
disgusted about what my uncontrolled
sexual Cravings had almost led me to do
and I felt humiliated and I violently
hated the psychiatrist
okay
um just then there came a major turning
point in my life like a phoenix I burst
From the Ashes of my despair to a
glorious New Hope I thought I wanted to
kill that psychiatrist because the
future looked utterly empty to me I felt
I wouldn't care if I died and so I said
to myself why not really kill the
psychiatrist and anyone else whom I hate
what is important is not the words that
ran through my mind but the way I felt
about them what was entirely new was the
fact that I really felt I could kill
someone my very hopelessness had
liberated me because I no longer cared
about death I no longer cared about
consequences and I said to myself that I
really could break out of my rut in life
and do things that were daring
irresponsible or Criminal
so being is how he might have written
this when he was much younger I kind of
think that ties back into what I think
John Smith was saying earlier that maybe
this whole Manifesto thing that you
wrote was just like a really really
long-winded justification for
just killing random people which he
wanted to do from then like I mean from
that paragraph that he wrote it really
just sounds like he wanted to kill
people because he was mad and humiliated
and he for some reason offloaded that
humiliation onto the psychiatrist
um and that made him like so he turned
everything outward like you like the
world is making me feel like this so I'm
gonna take revenge on the world it could
be that could be that he wanted to kill
a bunch of people but then he had to say
well who do I select right so he selects
targets and he goes who are the worst
people on the planet and then he comes
up with these guys I kind of feel like
that was probably more along the lines
right because these guys that are trying
to enslave Humanity yeah
really from what I took of
reading it was I read it a long time ago
or [ __ ] and then I heard it again on
audiobook probably about a year ago you
can hear it on YouTube
a lot of the [ __ ] that he says is is is
is either true or based and true or
based in truth or
it's something that might be true and
you're just kind of it reminded me a lot
of [ __ ] AJ from Infowars with
technocrats technocracy and uh [ __ ] that
corporations bad corporations do
so
I kind of thought there was something to
it but
doesn't mean there's anything really to
take Kaczynski I guess you know what I
mean like like you said he may just
wanted to kill a bunch of people and
they just selected who he thought was
the worst people
yeah and the thing about it is that
sometimes like I said and particularly
in people that are really intelligent
like this
sometimes
um they have particular [ __ ] up base
urges but they will construct these
really Byzantine elaborate
justifications for doing that to make
themselves feel better about it so you
know maybe he just wanted to kill people
because like I said he felt humiliated
or he felt like insecure or something
like that and he wanted to kill people
and maybe that made him feel guilty or
it made him feel bass or stupid or
something like that so he's like well I
have to have I'm not saying this is what
he consciously thought but he's like
well I have to have some kind of reason
I have to have some kind of so he
constructed this the very high-minded
sounding philosophy that would
essentially give him justification for
killing just random people that he
wanted true though I'm pretty sure he
thought oh I'm not saying that I was
like I'm just saying that's immaterial
I'm just saying that it might have been
something yeah he might have believed it
was true but he used that as a reason
and a justification for killing people
like to make himself feel better about
doing he's like I gotta have to kill
some people who should I kill who's who
who's the enemy and who's the enemy of
mankind I'm Gonna Save the World you
know it was that kind of mentality you
can kind of hear that in his writings or
you know or even in an audio book
somebody reading it he's trying to save
the world
from evil
in his opinion
you know
I was going to watch [ __ ] like
that yeah
another thing that he said this was also
from his uh diary was I intend to start
killing people if I am successful at
this it is possible that when I am
caught not alive I fervently hope there
will be some speculation in the news
media as to my motives for killing as in
the case of Charles Whitman who killed
some 13 people in Texas in the 60s we
did a show about him as well yeah if
such speculation occurs they are bound
to make me out to be a sickie and to
ascribe to me motives of assorted or
sick type I kind of feel like that's why
he was like writing everything down
because he didn't want people to think
that he was just crazy or mentally ill
and that's why he was doing it like he
had a reason but like I said I remember
when they arrested him they offered him
an insanity plea and he kept turned it
down no that's yeah and I said that
earlier like he was adamant that he
would not take an insane any plea he
absolutely he wanted people to read his
Manifesto yeah he wanted people to know
why he was doing it right and back in
the old media back then you really
couldn't really find out very easily
what it was the why he did it you'd have
to get those old uh newspaper or
articles that printed his [ __ ]
and they were long gone by the time you
saw that on television yeah so it wasn't
like you could just [ __ ] get on
Google and pull it up
back then
I didn't know what it was about really
at the time
it wasn't until later I was able to
figure out what had happened yeah that's
the way a lot of the a lot of the life
was pre-internet you don't really know
what it is
you're just taking the news at their
word and you really don't not really
sure you can believe them depending on
what it was like I didn't believe a lot
of that Waco stuff
like I could tell that they set those
people up did we do a show about that we
did did we yeah we did yeah yeah I
thought we did there was absolutely no
reason for the Waco [ __ ] raid if they
wanted David koresh they knew he went
into town all the time they could have
just arrested him in town they just
wanted to have a big training Mission
and have it look good on television and
justify the [ __ ] uh training budget
for eight you know ATF that's really all
it was
it was going to be a real good Mission
they thought it was going to be easy
some you could put on television look at
see hey yeah we're we're making our
money no the [ __ ] Branch Davidians
fought back and then they all died it
was a [ __ ] disaster for ATF you know
dumb
and then they're [ __ ] flaunted
[ __ ]
badass [ __ ] SWAT team [ __ ] I
remember seeing that [ __ ] on [ __ ]
television we were in the Army at the
time watching it
they're a badass SWAT team getting up on
top of the roof
bravely trying to duck in through the
window and then you can see the bullet
holes [ __ ] as they were shooting out
the [ __ ] side of the shooting through
the walls like I told you guys [ __ ]
that's what Pros actually do you know
I've got guys with [ __ ] Belfair
machine gun experience they're shooting
through the walls and they just [ __ ]
sent that [ __ ] entry team [ __ ]
running
legs [ __ ] flapping shot them full of
holes yeah
just because you're in those uniforms
there's not has no protection
you thought it was going to be easy no
some of them dudes died
and then all those Davidians died and
all the little kids cooked
[ __ ] terrible had their children down
underneath there
and they could have just arrested the
dude when he went into town but they
wanted a big spectacle
Senora sticks says High Intelligence is
technically a mental illness yeah in
some ways it is which only has 150 once
you get up in that yeah well that's the
thing and it's not any fault of their
like usually like intelligence is a good
thing um generally but once you get so
intelligent that you're like
significantly more intelligent than
people around you then you're gonna
suffer because one you know you're a lot
more aware of [ __ ] that's going on too
you don't really have that much in
common with people anymore so you're
very like it's very isolating
um you know and you're not gonna like
your interests are gonna be different
it's just you're almost like a species
apart you know what I mean and it's just
hard for you to fit in and I think
that's what happened to Ted because he
skipped a couple grades in school he was
so far ahead of everyone else and
so he really had a kind of thing and
like I said I went to school with a kid
like this
that skipped um at least one grade maybe
two and so like in high school he was a
couple years younger than everyone else
and he was much smaller than everyone
else and you know he was kind of what
they would call like you know nerdy and
so he got picked on he got bullied and
he was not emotionally mature
you know to the same level as some of
the other teenagers and so he was having
all kind of problems like a lot of times
like he would have like Tantrums like in
the class and stuff because he was a kid
still and I think kind of the same thing
happened with Ted I don't know like what
the solution is because
you know it's kind of a situation where
I mean I guess it's good that they take
someone there's like you know gifted
programs and stuff like that but you
should never send little kids to [ __ ]
University I don't think yeah I don't
know if that's such a great idea like I
get that I mean maybe they can have some
other programs for them maybe they can
do like some kind of homeschooling thing
or some kind of like thing where they
can just maybe take classes there with
other kids like that that are their same
age at least put that kid on vacation to
his college age yeah I mean I don't
think it's a great idea to like throw a
16 year old yeah
um into a college with like a bunch of
like 18 19 20 year olds I mean that's a
huge maturity Gap yeah and he's not
gonna be able to compete in the sexual
Market what the [ __ ] yeah it's like yeah
he might be smarter than all those
people but he's not socially Adept as
those people apologies about getting
laid a lot of it so you know why the
[ __ ] you know you don't send a little
kid to that so I mean you know I kind of
feel like that's probably not a great
idea like I said I get why they do it
like yeah they get bored and they like
stir up [ __ ] but there has to be some
other way there has to be some other way
like people that are that intelligent
they really need like I don't know like
individual schooling or something like
that like tutoring yeah some kind of
tutoring so so they don't like I said
because if you let them just like be in
the in the class with like people that
aren't as intelligent as them they're
gonna get bored and they're gonna start
acting up and that's not good either
because then all the other kids aren't
learning but you know you have to have
some kind of solution and I don't think
that's the best thing to do because I
think that really like [ __ ] him up I
mean there was a lot of stuff that
[ __ ] him up like over the course of
his life but so basically they were at
first when he got arrested they were
seeking the death penalty although
um the uh his brother David came in and
said please don't give him the death pen
he's like I would hate to think that I
turned my brother in and then he got
killed for Christ's sake
um so he basically said I really don't
want him to get that but um basically so
what Ted ended up doing was that he
avoided the death penalty by pleading
guilty to all of the charges so he
actually pled guilty in uh January of
1998 and then later he actually
attempted to withdraw the guilty plea
saying that it was involuntary but you
know all the requests were denied so
basically they just put him in prison he
got like uh life's I think it was like
eight life sentences or something like
that uh no possibility of parole and he
is as far as I know he's still uh
sitting in adx Florence the uh maximum
facility super max which is in Florence
Colorado
and he's still there so like I said he's
been writing his ass off in prison he's
written all kind of like uh all kind of
uh letters they said that he's
maintained regular correspondence with
over 400 people they keep all the stuff
too like they keep all the um copies of
all the stuff so they keep it in uh in a
collection and [ __ ] like that
um oh interestingly Wikipedia said the
names of most correspondents will be
kept sealed until 2049. so I'm assuming
like John Smith mentioned earlier that
probably the FBI is like keeping tabs on
like who he's writing to in case there's
like some other [ __ ] out there
like him that he's writing to but yeah
they also auctioned off a bunch of his
stuff to um
you know make back money to like give to
the victims families [ __ ] like that
and uh he actually kind of sued about
that like because he's like oh freedom
of expression you can't like auction my
stuff off but he lost so there you go
um and I think that's probably dude is
that it
yeah 2010 they published a collection of
his essays and a corrected version of
the manifesto so I guess he went in
there and like but yeah they uh they
republished it in 2010 under the title
technological slavery
and as I mentioned earlier his brother
has been writing to him every month
uh as long as his as Ted has been in
prison and he has never received a reply
because I guess Ted still feels betrayed
that his brother turned him in which
like I said I don't blame his brother
for turning him in that was the right
thing to do I know it's like was
probably terrible and hard to do but had
to be done he was killing innocent
people like I said
Jeffy Hart said how about some sort of
enrichment Program for Young Geniuses
something that would offer the kid
opportunities to discover themselves
while Tiding them over for a few years I
mean I kind of feel like
when I was in school like in the let's
see it would have been early 80s
they had just started doing I don't know
what they call it nowadays because I
don't have kids but um back in those
days they could you know the gifted
programmer at least at first they called
it the enrichment program and then they
called it gifted program
but what they did at first was that you
would go to like regular classes but
then once a week
at first when I was in I think it
started in when I was in third grade
maybe earlier but at first they would
take me and a couple other kids and they
would bus you to a different school and
then they would have like other classes
in there you know like more advanced or
whatever the [ __ ]
um but then they so they started doing
that like my first few years of
elementary school and then in fourth
grade or fifth grade they went to like
full time where they pulled all the
quote unquote gifted kids out and put
them in their own classes like separate
from everybody else
um but prior to that we just went like I
think it was once a week
but my when I was in um fifth grade I
actually really liked them because they
were you know they taught you like
regular [ __ ] but they were a lot more
unstructured so you got to do like all
these really cool projects and all this
other kind of like immersive kind of
stuff that you maybe probably wouldn't
get to do like in a more regular class
but I don't know I kind of like the idea
of just doing it like once a week or
just have being like one class and then
being with regular
but and I mean once we got into junior
high obviously
we had you know regular classes too
because you had to do gym and you had to
do that kind of [ __ ] you know in health
class and everybody had to take those so
you only had a few classes that were
quote unquote Advanced or AP or whatever
the [ __ ] they called them back then but
in elementary school like my last couple
years of elementary school they did full
time but before that it was just like
once a week I don't know how they do it
nowadays because like I said it's been a
long time since I've been at school a
long long time
um all right so I guess we're done
talking about you are right you seem
like I'm [ __ ] sleep and I'm getting
ready to fall asleep yeah you're getting
ready well it's only 8 30. I've been
drinking all day well that's your fault
writing down riding down to the biker
bar I don't know a little bit all right
I'll make something a little bit all
right uh so yeah I guess we'll wrap it
up hopefully you guys enjoyed this show
this evening this was actually like a
really interesting topic and I can't
believe that we hadn't done it up until
now but now we've done it now we have to
do Timothy McVeigh I guess because
that's another one that I was surprised
that I didn't do but we'll get to that
one eventually as well so yeah as I said
hopefully you guys enjoyed the show
thank you for stopping by thank you for
chatting with us thank you for super
chats if you gave us any and we will see
you guys again on Friday evening when we
do our Friday night Side Track show
which if you're new here we just kind of
have drinks I mean we have drinks now
but where we just have drinks and talk
about whatever we don't have a you know
we don't have a topic we just talk about
whatever comes up and chat with you guys
so hopefully you can come and join us
for that uh and we'll see you guys again
on Friday night good night